Hello, Happy Wednesday, everyone. Hi there. Listen, summer is almost over. Labor Day is upon us. It's almost back to school. We thought we needed one last little break. We do need one last little break, and we hope you guys have a great week.
大家好，周三快乐。大家好。听着，夏天快结束了。劳动节快到了。马上又要开学了。我们觉得我们需要最后放松一下。我们确实需要最后放松一下，祝大家有个美好的一周。
We thought you could use one last trip to the beach. So here is a rerun of Beach Games. We'll see you next week with an all new episode, Counseling. Bye. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
我们觉得大家可以去海滩做最后一次旅行。所以这里是《海滩运动会》的重播。下周我们会带全新一集《咨询》与大家见面。再见。我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Angela. Hey.
现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。安吉拉。嘿。
We are so excited today, you guys. We're going to the beach today. We're going to play some beach games. Yes. Season 3, episode 22, written by Jen Salada and Greg Daniels, directed by Harold Ramis. It's Beach Games. We have so much to talk about.
大家今天真是太兴奋了。我们今天要去的沙滩。我们要去玩沙滩游戏。是的。第三季第二集，由珍·萨拉达和格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯导演。这就是《海滩运动会》。我们有太多话要说了。
I kind of feel like we just got to get to it. We should dive in because I took very diligent notes. And I think you did in real life. We'll get to that. All right, here's a summary. Michael is invited to interview for a job opening at corporate. Certain that he's a lock for the job,
我总觉得我们得切入正题了。我们应该深入探讨一下，因为我做了非常认真的笔记。我想你在现实生活中也是这样。我们待会儿会说到这个。好吧，这是一个总结。迈克尔被邀请去公司面试一个空缺职位。他确信自己稳操胜券，
he takes his employees to the beach at Lake Scranton and holds a series of challenges to determine his successor. At the end of the day, Michael sets up a coal walk as a final challenge. Pam does the coal walk and summons up the courage to tell Jim and the whole office her real feelings. Oh, man. That was so tough to watch.
他带着员工来到斯克兰顿湖的沙滩上，举行了一系列挑战来决定他的继任者。在结束时，迈克尔设置了一场走炭火作为最终挑战。帕姆走了炭火，鼓起勇气向吉姆和整个办公室表达了她的真实感受。哦，天哪。那一幕看着太心酸了。
It was beautiful, Jenna. Pam broke my heart in this episode. Yeah, I had not seen this episode since it aired. And it shocked me. And I did it. And I was still shocked. Isn't that funny, like the way the brain works, where you're like, wait, I did all that.
那太美了，珍娜。在这集中，帕姆让我心碎。是的，自从这集播出后，我就再没看过。它震撼了我。而且我是亲历者，我依然被震撼了。这不是很奇妙吗，就像大脑运作的方式一样，你会想，等等，这一切都是我做的。
That's crazy. That's kind of cool. Yeah. So fast fact number one, Angela, our beach games is set on Lake Scranton. Yes. Obviously, we didn't go to the real Lake Scranton. But I did want to just talk a little bit about it.
这太疯狂了。这挺酷的。好的，第一个有趣的事实，安吉拉，我们的海滩运动会是以斯克兰顿湖为背景的。是的。显然，我们没有去真正的斯克兰顿湖。但我确实想稍微聊聊它。
Oh, let's hear it. Well, Lake Scranton is actually a reservoir. And it was built with a dam in the early 1900s. The dam was built by William Walker Scranton. And the body of water it created was originally called the Burnt Bridge Reservoir. Although the public calls it Lake Scranton. Well, Jenna, you and I have both been to Scranton.
哦，说来听听。斯克兰顿湖其实是一个水库。它是在20世纪初通过修建一座水坝建成的。这座水坝是由威廉·沃克·斯克兰顿建造的。它形成的水体最初被称为“烧毁桥水库”。尽管公众称之为斯克兰顿湖。好吧，珍娜，你我都去过斯克兰顿。
And one of the times that I went, they drove me around Lake Scranton. And it is so pretty. So pretty. There is a running track around the real Lake Scranton. And it's absolutely gorgeous. But I did look up a few facts about it, Ange. Yeah?
我去的其中一次，他们开车带我参观了斯克兰顿湖。它太漂亮了。太漂亮了。真正的斯克兰顿湖周围有一条跑步径。它绝对美极了。不过我确实查了一些关于它的资料，安吉？是吗？
Swimming is not permitted. Boating is not permitted, but canoeing and kayaking is allowed. I wonder why you can't swim in it. Like, I get the no motor, right? That's like, I think that's sort of really cool. But I wonder why the no swimming. I don't know. I'm not sure.
不允许游泳。不允许划船，但允许划独木舟和皮划艇。我想知道为什么不能在里面游泳。我是说，我理解不能用机动船，对吧？我觉得那挺酷的。但我想知道为什么不能游泳。我不知道。我不确定。
We're intrigued. Scranton, write us. Tell us why you can't swim in your lake. Well, this leads me to fast fact number two. I brought up all these facts about Lake Scranton because we had a fan question from Sophia B. Aaron W, Dana D, Marin B, and Faye B. Where was the beach that you filmed this episode?
我们很感兴趣。斯克兰顿的听众，写信给我们。告诉我们为什么你们的湖不能游泳。好吧，这让我想到了第二个有趣的事实。我之所以提出所有关于斯克兰顿湖的事实，是因为我们收到了索菲亚·B、亚伦·W、达娜·D、马林·B和费伊·B的粉丝提问。你们拍摄这一集的沙滩在哪里？
Was it a long commute? And how many days did you film at that location? Well, I will tell you. Tell us. I know. I remember one or two things. But I bet you got all the details, so let's hear it. Well, I reached out to Kentipedian.
通勤时间长吗？你们在这个地方拍摄了几天？好吧，我会告诉你的。告诉我们。我知道。我记得一两件事。但我敢打赌你掌握了所有细节，所以说来听听吧。好吧，我联系了肯蒂皮迪安。
Here's what he told me. We filmed at the beach at the Hanson Dam Recreation Center in Silmar. We shot there for four days and nights. Will you mention that you've been to the real Lake Scranton? I've been to this real Hanson Dam Recreation Center outside of us filming. You have?
他是这么对我们的。我们在西尔马的汉森大坝休闲中心的沙滩上拍摄。我们在那里拍摄了四天四夜。你提到过你去过真正的斯克兰顿湖吗？除了拍摄之外，我也去过这个真正的汉森大坝休闲中心。你去过？
Yes, because there is this museum, this children's museum, called the Discovery Cube that's right nearby. And when you go through this area, there's also an equestrian center. There's an aquatic center. There's a playground. Because lady, the place that they put us to film this episode was like, I had no idea all this stuff was there.
是的，因为那里有一个博物馆，一个儿童博物馆，叫做探索立方体，就在附近。当你穿过这个区域时，还有一个马术中心。有一个水上中心。有一个游乐场。因为天哪，他们让我们拍摄这一集的地方，我根本不知道所有这些东西都在那里。
My memory of where we filmed was it was like a chemical pond runoff from a dam, where I was like, are we breathing in fumes? It was really gross. They, maybe the only place they let you film is in this weird janky corner of this area. Where the runoff water goes. Yeah, because this recreation center is actually really nice.
我对我们拍摄地点的记忆是，它就像是一个大坝排出的化学废水池，当时我在想，我们是在吸入毒气吗？真的很恶心。他们，也许他们唯一允许你拍摄的地方就是这个地区的这个奇怪的、破烂的角落。废水排到的地方。是的，因为这个休闲中心其实非常漂亮。
But here's something I found out, too. The lake where we filmed is filled with circulated drinking water. What? Yeah, circulated drinking water. And it offers fishing and public boating. Oh, my gosh. So when Ed is out there floating in the water,
但我还发现了一件事。我们拍摄的湖里充满了循环饮用水。什么？是的，循环饮用水。它提供钓鱼和公共划船服务。哦，天哪。所以当埃德漂浮在水中的时候，
he was in some recycled drinking water. Oh, well, that's good to know. All these years, I worried for him that he was going to get some kind of weird rash. All right, well, let's move on to fastback number three. So like we said earlier, this was written by both Greg Daniels and Jen Solada. And we reached out to Jen Solada.
他在一些循环利用的饮用水里。哦，那真是庆幸。这些年里，我还一直担心他会得什么奇怪的皮疹呢。好吧，让我们继续第三个有趣的事实。所以正如我们刚才所说，这集是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和珍·萨拉达共同编剧的。我们联系了珍·萨拉达。
And she sent us audio clips. She sent us so many. She's so gracious. We're going to sprinkle them throughout. But here, she has one for us right now. Yes, she is going to tell us a little bit about the inspiration for this episode and what it was like to write a script with Greg. I think the inspiration for this episode was just survivor.
她给我们发了音频片段。她发了好多。她太亲切了。我们会在节目中穿插播放这些音频。现在她就有一个音频片段要给我们听。是的，她将向我们讲述这一集的灵感来源，以及与格雷格一起写剧本是什么感觉。我想这集的灵感来源就是《幸存者》。
I think it was Greg's idea. And I remember all of us talking about survivor being a perfect way for Michael Scott to pick his successor. I mean, what other way would this man use to try to pick somebody who could run a branch? It just seemed like a no-brainer for Michael Scott to do it this way. And then we tried to sit down and write the whole thing together.
我想这是格雷格的想法。我记得我们所有人都讨论过，《幸存者》是迈克尔·斯科特挑选接班人的绝佳方式。我的意思是，这个男人还会用什么其他方式来试图挑选一个能管理分公司的人呢？迈克尔·斯科特用这种方式做这件事简直再理所当然不过了。然后我们试着坐下来一起写完整集。
And we were like, this isn't going to work. So we divided it up. We can't remember exactly how we did it. I think sometimes with Paul, when I'd write a script with Paul, I'd do the first half, he'd do the second or vice versa. And with Greg, I think we didn't do it cleanly divided up that way. I think just he did some of the scenes. I did others.
然后我们觉得，这行不通。所以我们把它分工了。我们记不清具体是怎么做的了。我想有时候我和保罗合作写剧本时，我写前半部分，他写后半部分，反之亦然。至于格雷格，我觉得我们没有分得那么清楚。我想只是他写了一些场景。我写了别的。
And I do remember that the Pam speech was mostly Greg. And I think that is such a beautiful part of the episode. And the Pam arc pre-existed the idea of the Beach Games episode. So I think some of the ideas from that speech were in his notes. But I love that part. It is one of my favorite parts, not my favorite part of the episode. So credit to Greg for that part for sure. But we both wrote a bunch of it.
我确实记得帕姆的演讲主要是格雷格写的。我认为那是这一集中非常精彩的部分。而且帕姆的故事线在《海滩运动会》这一集的想法产生之前就已经存在了。所以我认为那段演讲中的一些想法已经在他的笔记里了。但我很喜欢那部分。它是我最喜欢的片段之一，说不定就是我最喜欢的一集片段。所以这部分绝对要归功于格雷格。不过我们两个都写了很多。
I just don't think we clearly divided it up. Well, Ange, I remember Greg talking to me about this Pam arc of finding her voice. And he planted this idea a few episodes ago. And we sprinkled it in. And so I just love this idea that he'd been maybe writing down little notes about what Pam will finally say when she says something. And I remember getting the script for this episode and just being so excited as an actor. There was just so much to chew on.
我只是觉得我们没有分工得那么明确。好吧，安吉，我记得格雷格跟我谈过关于帕姆寻找自我声音的故事线。他在几集前就埋下了这个伏笔。我们一点点把它穿插进去了。所以我真的很喜欢这个想法，也许他一直在记一些小笔记，关于帕姆最终说话时会说些什么。我记得拿到这集剧本时，作为一个演员，我真的是兴奋极了。有太多可以细细品味的东西了。
I mean, I thought that it was just beautifully done. Really, just Pam's whole journey this season about even her sending the wrong beer back. You know what I mean? Yeah. And just having these moments where she stood up for herself and spoke her truth. And it all builds to this one moment. And it's just so well done. When I was rewatching this, I was marveling at what a well written episode this was.
我的意思是，我觉得它拍得太美了。真的，仅仅是帕姆这一季的整个心路历程，甚至包括她把错误的啤酒退回去。你知道我的意思吗？是的。而且只要有这些时刻，她就能为自己挺身而出，说出内心的真实想法。这一切都在这一刻汇聚爆发。而且拍得太好了。当我重新观看这一集时，我惊叹于这是一集多么出色的剧本。
Yes. Well, maybe we should take a quick break and then come back and break down this episode. I can't wait. Jenna, we have so much to talk about. I know we've been trading a lot of texts about this one. All right, so this episode starts with this very funny cold open. It is Dwight and Michael. They're in Michael's office.
是的。好吧，也许我们应该稍作休息，然后回来剖析这一集。我等不及了。珍娜，我们有太多要聊的了。我知道我们为这一集交流了很多短信。好吧，这一集从一个非常搞笑的开场白开始。是德怀特和迈克尔。他们在迈克尔的办公室里。
And Michael's convinced that he's sick, you guys. He's convinced they're scrolling through a website. It's like WebMD or something, trying to figure out what he is sick from. Dwight's very concerned. Yes. Pam has a talking head where she explains that this happens about 40 times a year. Michael, it's sick but has no symptoms. Yes.
迈克尔坚信自己生病了，伙计们。他坚信他们在浏览一个网站。就像WebMD之类的，试图找出自己得了什么病。德怀特非常担心。是的。帕姆有一个对着镜头的独白，她解释说这种情况一年大约发生40次。迈克尔，生病了但没有任何症状。是的。
Well, Jen left us a really great audio clip about this, about the inspiration for this cold open. Sam, can you play that? Greg and I wrote the episode together and it was really fun. I remember being really curious, what is Greg's process going to be like? Because writing scripts, it was such a solitary part of what we did. And so I was always wondering, like, what are other writers like when they go off to write a script?
珍给我们留下了非常棒的音频片段，讲述了这个开场的灵感来源。山姆，你能放一下吗？我和格雷格一起写了这一集，真的很有趣。我记得我很好奇，格雷格的创作过程会是什么样的？因为写剧本是我们所做事情中非常独立的一部分。所以我总是很好奇，当其他编剧去写剧本时，他们是什么样的？
It became quickly obvious that his process at the beginning was like mine, which is like every other writer I've ever met, which is there's a fair amount of procrastinating right away before you have to get into the hard work. It's figuring out what you want to eat. It's sharpening your pencils. It's figuring out the temperature of the room. And for both of us, we started focusing on ailments, like what was wrong, how we weren't feeling well, like my ear was bothering him and he wasn't feeling super well at the time.
很快就很明显，他一开始的创作过程和我一样，就像我见过的所有其他编剧一样，那就是在必须开始艰苦的工作之前，总会有相当长的一段时间在拖延。要想吃什么。是要削铅笔。是要搞清楚房间的温度。对我们俩来说，我们开始关注病情，比如哪里不对劲，我们是怎么感觉不舒服的，比如我的耳朵一直困扰着他，而他当时也感觉很不舒服。
And so we went on WebMD and we tried to diagnose ourselves and each other. And they used to have a little body where you could like point to the part of the body that hurt and that was bothering you. And so he diagnosed me with an ear infection or at least inner ear congestion. And he ended up putting some oil from the kitchen that we found in my ear. It turns out you can do this. It is, it is a home remedy and it helped. It helped my ear.
于是我们上了WebMD，试图诊断我们自己和对方。他们过去有一个小身子模型，你可以指着身体疼痛或困扰你的部位。于是他诊断我得了耳部感染，或者至少是内耳充血。他最后把我从厨房找到的一些油滴进我耳朵里。事实证明你可以这么做。这确实是一个偏方，而且管用了。它帮到了我的耳朵。
And I think we diagnosed him with walking pneumonia. So we did this right when we were sent off to write the Beach Games episode and it ended up becoming our cold open because we were probably looking for a cold open and we're like, what about what we're doing right now? There is so much about that audio clip that I love. I think it's so relatable. It's like whenever you sit down to do something and it doesn't matter what it is. I mean, there's was this writing assignment, but all the different ways you procrastinate
我想我们诊断他得了行走性肺炎。所以我们刚好在被派去写《海滩运动会》这一集时做了这件事，它最终成了我们的开场白，因为我们可能在找一个开场白，然后我们想，我们现在正在做的不就是吗？那个音频片段里有太多我喜欢的内容了。我觉得它太有共鸣了。这就好像每当你坐下来要做某事时，不管是什么事。我的意思是，那是一个写作任务，但你在做那件事之前会用各种各样的方式拖延。
before you get to that thing. Yes. Well, Angela, you and I are working on a project that we can't say exactly what it is, but it involves quite a bit of writing and I, every time I sit down to write, I will write one sentence and then I will get up and get a snack and then I'll come back and write a sentence and then I'll be like, I need more coffee. Yeah. It's like the procrastination.
是的。好吧，安吉拉，你和我正在合作一个项目，我们不能确切地说是什么，但它涉及相当多的写作，我，每次我坐下来写作，我都会写一句话，然后我会起来拿个零食，然后我回来写一句话，然后我会想，我需要更多的咖啡。是的。就像拖延症一样。
I loved that she shared that because I think my perception is always that creativity comes easy to people who are successful. I always think like it must pour out of them and it is such a slog. So I loved hearing that. But then the other thing I loved was that their procrastination, it got turned into a story idea, like it's worth it, like all of that nonsense. It produced something. Right.
我很喜欢她分享这个，因为我一直以来的看法是，成功人士的创造力总是轻而易举地到来。我总觉得这些灵感一定是从他们身上倾泻而出的，而实际上这是一个极其费力的过程。所以我很高兴听到这个。但另一件我喜欢的事是，他们的拖延症竟然变成了一个故事创意，感觉这一切都是值得的，所有这些废话。它产生了一些东西。对的。
Well, I had a writing professor in college that used to always say, write what you know. Write what you know and it will be honest. Oh, well, I just loved this, this opening. And you know, before they can really diagnose Michael, Pam walks in the office and says, David Wallace is on the phone. Yeah. It's very clear that David Wallace does not call very often. No, it's a big deal.
我在大学里有一位写作教授，他过去常常说，写你所知道的。写你所知道的，它就会是真诚的。哦，我真的很喜欢这个开场。你知道的，在他们真正诊断出迈克尔之前，帕姆走进办公室说，大卫·华莱士在电话里。是的。很明显，大卫·华莱士不常打电话。不，这是一件大事。
Well Michael gets on the phone with him. Oh my goodness. Michael, what are you doing? Michael, the way Michael talks to his bosses or even when he goes to New York to corporate, there's such a casualness to how he relates to them that is so not work appropriate. It's so true. Well, we find out the reason that David Wallace is calling is because there is a job opening at corporate and he would like Michael to apply.
迈克尔接了他的电话。哦，天哪。迈克尔，你在干什么？迈克尔，迈克尔跟他的老板说话的方式，甚至当他去纽约总公司时，他对他们的态度有一种随性，完全不符合工作场合的规范。确实如此。我们发现大卫·华莱士打电话的原因是公司有一个空缺职位，他想让迈克尔申请。
I can't believe he still wants Michael to apply after this phone call. But I think Michael has a very, very good sales record and a good record of connecting with people out in the sales world. Yeah, he's a really good salesman. Here's a little interesting tidbit, Jenna. There was a scene that was deleted right after this phone call of David Wallace and Michael. David Wallace calls Jim and tells Jim the same thing. I saw that in the script.
我真不敢相信在通完这个电话后他还想让迈克尔申请。但我认为迈克尔有着非常非常好的销售记录，在销售界与人沟通的记录也很好。是的，他是个非常优秀的销售员。这里有一个有趣的小花絮，珍娜。在大卫·华莱士和迈克尔通完这个电话后，有一个被删掉的场景。大卫·华莱士打电话给吉姆，告诉吉姆同样的事情。我在剧本里看到了。
And they chose not to use it. They chose to like reveal it later that it's Jim calling. It's Jim being more proactive in his life. But there was a version where David calls Jim. Yeah, I noticed that in the script because that scene on the beach with Jim and Karen calling David and kind of asking if they could go for the job as well, that was not in the original script. So that must have been something that they added later.
他们选择不使用它。他们选择稍后才透露是吉姆打来的电话。这体现了吉姆在生活中更加积极主动。但确实有一个版本是大卫打电话给吉姆的。是的，我在剧本里注意到了这一点，因为吉姆和Karen在沙滩上打电话给大卫并询问他们是否也可以去争取这个职位的那个场景，并不在最初的剧本中。所以那一定他们后来添加的。
Well, I remember when we were at the beach, there were a few scenes that sort of happened on the fly. They were like kind of pitched in the moment. And that was one of them. Yeah. So now it is beach day. And at two minutes, 28 seconds, you get a fantastic look at Michael's outfit. He clearly bought everything he could at Sandals in the gift shop.
好吧，我记得我们在海滩上时，有一些场景是即兴发挥的。它们就像是当场提出的点子。这就是其中之一。好吧，现在是海滩日。在两分二十八秒时，你可以好好欣赏一下迈克尔的行头。他显然把桑德尔斯礼品店里所有能买的东西都买下了。
He's got a t-shirt. He's got a hat. He has a necklace that he probably bought there, a little pucachel necklace. He's really ready. And he tells everyone they better go potty before they leave. I'm just like, Michael's so ready to be a dad. You know? He just is.
他有一件T恤。他有一顶帽子。他有一条他可能在那里买的项链，一条小贝壳项链。他真的是准备就绪了。他告诉大家离开前最好去上个厕所。我当时就想，迈克尔太适合当爸爸了。你知道吗？他就是这样。
Bless his heart. And you get to see everybody in casual attire, and I just loved it. Well, I noticed something about our wardrobe. What's that? Do you see how many layers we all have on? Oh, well, that was for a reason. Yep. It was because we shot this episode in March, and we knew that that location was going to
真可怜。你还能看到每个人都穿着休闲装，我太喜欢了。好吧，我注意到我们的服装有一个细节。是什么？你看到我们每个人身上穿了多少层衣服吗？哦，那是有原因的。是的。这是因为我们在三月份拍摄这一集，而且我们知道那个地方白天会
be perfectly warm and lovely during the day. It turned out to be hot as F. There was a heat wave. There was this crazy, freak, March heat wave. It was 98 degrees. I wrote in my journal that it was 98 degrees our first day. Yeah. But then when the sun went down, it was freezing cold.
非常温暖宜人。结果热得要命。有一场热浪。那是一场疯狂的、罕见的三月热浪。气温高达98华氏度。我在日记里写了第一天气温高达98华氏度。是的。但当太阳下山时，却冷得要命。
Yeah. We were in this valley, so it was like these really huge swings of temperature. Yeah. So Wardrobe tried to give us layers to help take us between these two extreme temperatures. And I noticed when I was looking at everyone's beach attire. Their layers. Well, you know what? I noticed this was really, really fun to me.
是的。我们在一个山谷里，所以温差非常巨大。是的。所以服装部门试图给我们穿多层衣服，帮助我们应对这两种极端温度。当我看着每个人的沙滩装时，我注意到了这一点。他们的多层衣服。好吧，你知道吗？我注意到这一点，觉得非常有意思。
Toby and Angela almost have on the same outfit. What? I did not notice that. They're both wearing these beige tops. They have huge beige floppy hats and like sort of like just like pants on, and they're also both obsessed with sunscreen, both of them. Well, I noticed that both Andy and Stanley are wearing a red polo shirt. Oh, yeah.
托比和安吉拉穿的几乎是同一套衣服。什么？我没有注意到。他们俩都穿着米色的上衣。他们戴着巨大的米色软呢帽，还穿着那种裤子，而且他们俩都对防晒霜着迷，两个人都这样。好吧，我注意到安迪和斯坦利都穿着红色的Polo衫。哦，是的。
I did not catch that. But guess what? I did catch. And I know it's your favorite moment of the day. Is it a new plant at reception? Because we need a sting for this. New plant alert. Three minutes, 32 seconds.
我没有注意到。但你猜怎么着？我注意到了。我知道这是你一天中最喜欢的时刻。是前台有新植物吗？因为我们需要一个音效。新植物警报。三分三十二秒。
It is a red flowering plant. There are big red flowers on this plant. Okay, I'm sorry. I see that as a metaphor because Pam is going to bloom in this episode. That is so good. Pam's going to flower. She's going to bloom. Well we forgot to talk about how Michael has told Toby he can't come on the beach day.
那是一株开红花的植物。这株植物上有大朵的红花。好吧，抱歉。我觉得这是一个隐喻，因为帕姆在这集中要绽放了。这太棒了。帕姆要开花了。她要绽放了。好吧，我们忘了说迈克尔是怎么告诉托比他不能去海滩日的。
Oh, that was so good. Toby's disappointment. He doesn't get to see you in a two piece. Jenna, I wrote, how did you get through that scene without laughing? I didn't. How did you do it? Because when you were like, oh, thanks. I'm going to wear my two piece.
哦，那太精彩了。托比太失望了。他看不到你穿两件套泳衣了。珍娜，我写道，你当时是怎么忍住不笑场拍完那场戏的？我没忍住。你是怎么做到的？因为当你表现得像，哦，谢谢。我要穿我的两件套。
His face is so good. It's so funny. We also didn't mention, and I'm tracking this, the Meredith flash count. This is flash number two. Yes. Meredith has that great talking head where she explains that she wore her bathing suit to work. Yeah.
他的表情太棒了。太搞笑了。我们也没提到，而且我一直在记录，那就是梅雷迪思露胸的次数。这是第二次。是的。梅雷迪思有一个精彩的独白，她解释说她穿着泳衣去上班。是的。
And she lifts her shirt to show you and she's like, oh shoot, it's in my purse. Michael has a special assignment for Pam on beach day. Of course, because she needs an assignment. Yeah, Michael tells her that she has to take notes all day on people's character, humor, charisma, and the indefinable qualities that they possess, but not their hotness per se. I loved that line. Yeah. Per se.
然后她掀起衬衫给你看，接着她说，哦糟了，在我的钱包里。迈克尔在海滩日给帕姆派了一个特殊任务。当然，因为她需要一个任务。是的，迈克尔告诉她，她必须一整天都在记录人们的性格、幽默感、个人魅力以及他们所具备的难以言喻的品质，但不是指他们的性感本身。我很喜欢这句台词。对。本身。
Like, she could add that if she wanted, but it's not 100% necessary, I guess. But he also doesn't tell her why she has to do this. No. He just needs to find out which of his employees has the skills to be a chicken with a head. That's right. That makes sense. What? Yeah.
就像，如果她想的话她可以加上这个，但我想这并不是100%必要的。但他也没有告诉她为什么要这么做。没有。他只需要找出他的哪个员工具备当领头鸡的技能。没错。这说得通。什么？对。
What? Well, let's see. Now the gang is all going to board the bus. Michael's got a big party bus to take everyone to the beach. Yeah. Creed's got a boogie board. He's ready to go. Yeah.
什么？好吧，我们来看看。现在大家都要上车了。迈克尔租了一辆大派对巴士带大家去海滩。是的。克里德拿着一块冲浪板。他准备好了。是的。
Kevin says he just wants to lay on the beach and eat hot dogs. Literally all he's ever wanted. Now this bus that we're all riding in, we really rode in that. That's how we got to the beach. That day, but then the days after that, we drove ourselves. Yes. That first day, though, they shuttled us from the stages, and the plan was that we would use the time to shoot the scene with Michael.
凯文说他只想躺在沙滩上吃热狗。字面意思，这是他一直以来唯一的愿望。现在我们坐的这辆大巴，我们真的是坐那辆车去的。那是我们去海滩的方式。那天，但之后的几天，我们都是自己开车去的。是的。不过第一天，他们用班车把我们从片场接送过去，计划是用这段时间拍摄迈克尔的戏份。
But then we had extra time. Yeah. So we all started singing. Well, listen, I watched the DVD commentary for this, and I thought it was so sweet because Harold Ramis is on the DVD commentary. And Jen Salada was on it as well, and Jen was like, you know, Harold said, I'd never been on a bus where we didn't sing. Yes.
But then we had extra time. Yeah. So we all started singing. Well, listen, I watched the DVD commentary for this, and I thought it was so sweet because Harold Ramis is on the DVD commentary. And Jen Salada was on it as well, and Jen was like, you know, Harold said, I'd never been on a bus where we didn't sing. Yes.|||但是后来我们有了多余的时间。对。所以我们大家开始唱歌。听着，我看了这集的 DVD 评论音轨，我觉得它太甜蜜了，因为哈罗德·雷米斯（Harold Ramis）在 DVD 评论音轨里。简·萨拉达（Jen Salada）也在里面，简当时就说，你知道的，哈罗德说，我从来没坐过一辆大家不唱歌的巴士。是的。
He was like, everybody, when you get on a bus with people, you sing, right? That was Harold Ramis being genius. And I do know two other songs we sang, Jenna. Do you remember? Yeah. What? What was the answer? Oh, yes.
He was like, everybody, when you get on a bus with people, you sing, right? That was Harold Ramis being genius. And I do know two other songs we sang, Jenna. Do you remember? Yeah. What? What was the answer? Oh, yes.|||他说，每个人，当你和大家一起上车时，你们都会唱歌，对吧？那是哈罗德·เร米斯（Harold Ramis）展现天才的一面。我知道我们还唱了另外两首歌，珍娜。你记得吗？对。什么？答案是什么？哦，是的。
And then we also sang Friends, and we did the hand claps. I remember that. Yeah. I didn't know all the words to that, so I just clapped. Well, Angela, I have to say, I remember that vibe of us just singing our way to the beach that very first day, and then, frankly, as we walked off the bus and got hit in the face with that 98-degree weather, I feel like you see that play out on our faces. I felt the same thing in rewatching this.
And then we also sang Friends, and we did the hand claps. I remember that. Yeah. I didn't know all the words to that, so I just clapped. Well, Angela, I have to say, I remember that vibe of us just singing our way to the beach that very first day, and then, frankly, as we walked off the bus and got hit in the face with that 98-degree weather, I feel like you see that play out on our faces. I felt the same thing in rewatching this.|||然后我们还唱了《老友记》主题曲，我们还击掌了。我记得那个。是的。我不知道那首歌的所有歌词，所以我只是鼓掌。嗯，安吉拉，我必须得说，我记得头一天我们一路唱歌去海滩的那种氛围，然后，坦白说，当我们走下巴士，迎面撞上那 98 华氏度（约 36.7 摄氏度）的天气时，我觉得你可以从我们的脸上看到那种反应。我在重看这一段时也有同感。
That shot when we're walking across the beach, we're all carrying our stuff, Meredith is dragging a cooler, do you know the shot I'm talking about? I took a photo of it, because I think it's so amazing. I took a screen grab. That is all real. That struggle to drag that stuff across the beach, and it was hot. You guys have all been there. You've been to that beach where you had to park super far away and lug your stuff in
That shot when we're walking across the beach, we're all carrying our stuff, Meredith is dragging a cooler, do you know the shot I'm talking about? I took a photo of it, because I think it's so amazing. I took a screen grab. That is all real. That struggle to drag that stuff across the beach, and it was hot. You guys have all been there. You've been to that beach where you had to park super far away and lug your stuff in|||就是那个我们走过海滩的镜头，我们都拎着东西，梅雷迪思拖着一个冷藏箱，你知道我在说哪个镜头吗？我拍了张照片，因为我觉得它太棒了。我截了屏。那全都是真的。那种把东西拖过海滩的挣扎，而且天气很热。你们都经历过。你们都去过那种必须把车停在超级远的地方，然后把东西大包小包扛进去的海滩……
the heat, and all your enthusiasm of getting there is so quickly like, oh, God, here we go. Well, Angela, you mentioned a little bit about the challenges of this location, and Jen talked about that as well. So Sam, will you play that audio clip number eight? It was a super fun episode, but it was really challenging. I remember even the bathrooms weren't close to the location, and there was close as they could be, but we needed a golf cart, and so anytime anybody had to go to the bathroom,
the heat, and all your enthusiasm of getting there is so quickly like, oh, God, here we go. Well, Angela, you mentioned a little bit about the challenges of this location, and Jen talked about that as well. So Sam, will you play that audio clip number eight? It was a super fun episode, but it was really challenging. I remember even the bathrooms weren't close to the location, and there was close as they could be, but we needed a golf cart, and so anytime anybody had to go to the bathroom,|||在酷热中，你刚到达时的所有热情瞬间就变成了“哦，天哪，开始受罪了”。嗯，安吉拉，你刚才稍微提到了这个外景地的挑战，简也谈到了这一点。所以，山姆，你能播放一下那个第八号音频剪辑吗？这是一集超级有趣的剧集，但真的极具挑战性。我记得甚至连洗手间都离拍摄地点不近，它们已经是能做到的最近距离了，但我们还是需要一辆高尔夫球车，所以每当有人要去洗手间……
there was a golf cart taking people up a hill, and I remember it was super hot and super cold all within the course of one day. There were heat lamps and hand warmers, and then it was really, really hot in the middle of the afternoon. So everything about this episode was a challenge, and I feel like we just, in order to get everything great, it just took a long time. Oh yeah, it was Slim Pickens out there on the beach. I mean, we had just enough room to shoot.
there was a golf cart taking people up a hill, and I remember it was super hot and super cold all within the course of one day. There were heat lamps and hand warmers, and then it was really, really hot in the middle of the afternoon. So everything about this episode was a challenge, and I feel like we just, in order to get everything great, it just took a long time. Oh yeah, it was Slim Pickens out there on the beach. I mean, we had just enough room to shoot.|||就会有一辆高尔夫球车带着大家上山，而且我记得就在同一天之内，天气时而超级热，时而超级冷。现场有取暖灯和暖手宝，然后到了下午正午时分又变得非常非常热。所以这一集的方方面面都是个挑战，我觉得我们为了把每个镜头都拍好，真的花了很长时间。哦，是的，海滩上的条件真是差劲透了。我的意思是，我们只有刚刚够用的空间来拍摄。
There was, I mean, I remember us just being huddled under, like, a little pop-up tent or something. Yeah, I mean, when I was looking at the photos that I have, there's nothing out there. Once we were on the beach, we were sort of on our own, because things couldn't be in the shot. They did get us, like, some lawn chairs. I have this great photo, Jenna, of Steve and I sitting next to each other, clearly between a scene, and we're just, like, in lawn chairs, like, just hanging out and talking.
There was, I mean, I remember us just being huddled under, like, a little pop-up tent or something. Yeah, I mean, when I was looking at the photos that I have, there's nothing out there. Once we were on the beach, we were sort of on our own, because things couldn't be in the shot. They did get us, like, some lawn chairs. I have this great photo, Jenna, of Steve and I sitting next to each other, clearly between a scene, and we're just, like, in lawn chairs, like, just hanging out and talking.|||这里有……我的意思是，我记得我们只是缩在一个小小的弹出式帐篷或者类似的东西下面。对，我的意思是，当我看着我留下的照片时，外面什么都没有。一旦我们上了海滩，我们就只能靠自己了，因为东西不能入镜。他们确实给我们弄了一些草坪椅。我有一张很棒的照片，珍娜，是史蒂夫和我坐在一起，显然是在两场戏之间，我们就像这样坐在草坪椅上，随便闲逛聊天。
I just love it. And also this week, Jenna, I brought my football, like, in real life, I had it in my car. And when they would have some setups to do, in particular, like, when they were setting up the hot dogs and all that, I have these photos of us throwing the football on the beach. Aw. We were having our own beach day. So yes, it was sort of like, there weren't bathrooms nearby, and it was hot, but we were
I just love it. And also this week, Jenna, I brought my football, like, in real life, I had it in my car. And when they would have some setups to do, in particular, like, when they were setting up the hot dogs and all that, I have these photos of us throwing the football on the beach. Aw. We were having our own beach day. So yes, it was sort of like, there weren't bathrooms nearby, and it was hot, but we were|||我太喜欢了。而且这周，珍娜，我带了我的橄榄球，就像在现实生活中一样，它就在我的车里。当他们需要进行一些布景时，特别是像他们正在摆放热狗之类的时候，我有这些我们在海滩上扔橄榄球的照片。哦。我们在过我们自己的海滩日。所以，是的，有点像，附近没有洗手间，天气又热，但我们……
also just making our own fun. And we always did that. I felt like as a group, Jenna. We were really just kind of roll with it and make the best of it, and I always loved that about our show. All right. Well, let's see. Where are we?
also just making our own fun. And we always did that. I felt like as a group, Jenna. We were really just kind of roll with it and make the best of it, and I always loved that about our show. All right. Well, let's see. Where are we?|||也在苦中作乐。我们一直都是这样。我觉得作为团队，珍娜。我们真的是那种兵来将挡、随遇而安的性格，并把事情做到最好，我一直都很喜欢我们剧的这一点。好吧。嗯，让我们看看。我们到哪儿了？
We've arrived. We're ganking our stuff down the beach, and Michael tells us it's time to start the funtivities. Such a great word. I want to use it. It's like nifty gifties. Funtivities. Like, can you imagine if I did that? Like at a family reunion.
We've arrived. We're ganking our stuff down the beach, and Michael tells us it's time to start the funtivities. Such a great word. I want to use it. It's like nifty gifties. Funtivities. Like, can you imagine if I did that? Like at a family reunion.|||我们到了。我们把东西拖过海滩，迈克尔告诉我们是时候开始“欢乐活动（funtivities）”了。多么棒的一个词。我想用它。就像“精美礼品（nifty gifties）”一样。“欢乐活动（Funtivities）”。比如，你能想象如果我这么做吗？就像在家庭聚会上一样。
All right, everybody, it's time for funtivities. I love it. I know. I love it. You and I would both be excited. We'd want to be on the funtivities, like organizing group. The funtivities committee. The funtivities committee.
All right, everybody, it's time for funtivities. I love it. I know. I love it. You and I would both be excited. We'd want to be on the funtivities, like organizing group. The funtivities committee. The funtivities committee.|||好了，各位，是时候进行欢乐活动了。我太喜欢了。我知道。我也好喜欢。你和我都会很兴奋。我们会想加入欢乐活动小组，比如负责组织的。欢乐活动委员会。欢乐活动委员会。
Or the committee to plan funtivities. Or what was wrong with my brain? The funtivities organizing group. What? Mama needs another cup of tea. Well, Michael tells everyone that they have to divide into teams. He picks the team leaders quote unquote randomly. They are Jim Dwight, Andy, and Stanley.
Or the committee to plan funtivities. Or what was wrong with my brain? The funtivities organizing group. What? Mama needs another cup of tea. Well, Michael tells everyone that they have to divide into teams. He picks the team leaders quote unquote randomly. They are Jim Dwight, Andy, and Stanley.|||或者计划欢乐活动的委员会。或者我的脑子怎么了？欢乐活动组织小组。什么？妈妈需要再来一杯茶。好吧，迈克尔告诉大家他们必须分成各个队伍。他“所谓地”随机挑选了队长。他们是吉姆、德怀特、安迪和斯坦利。
These guys are clearly his top contenders for the job. And he makes them choose their tribes. Yes. But not Pam. And then. Pam cannot be included. Pam can't be included. And also, these are the team names.
These guys are clearly his top contenders for the job. And he makes them choose their tribes. Yes. But not Pam. And then. Pam cannot be included. Pam can't be included. And also, these are the team names.|||这些人显然是他心目中最顶尖的人选。然后他让他们选择各自的部落。是的。但潘不行。然后。潘不能被包括在内。潘不能被算进去。而且，这些是队伍的名称。
Ready? Yes. We have Gryffindor, Voldemort, Blue, and USA. It's incredible. Yes. Well, I loved all of these Harry Potter references. You know, my son is right in that age range where we've got Harry Potter over here. And we reached out to Jen about this.
Ready? Yes. We have Gryffindor, Voldemort, Blue, and USA. It's incredible. Yes. Well, I loved all of these Harry Potter references. You know, my son is right in that age range where we've got Harry Potter over here. And we reached out to Jen about this.|||准备好了吗？是的。我们有格兰芬多、伏地魔、蓝色队和美国队。太不可思议了。是的。嗯，我喜欢所有这些《哈利·波特》的梗。你知道，我的儿子正处于那个年纪，我们家里到处都是《哈利·波特》。我们为此联系了简。
Yeah. What was up with the Harry Potter thing? Yeah, I was so curious. I was like, was this like an inside joke in the writer's room? And this is what Jen had to say. We had a bunch of Harry Potter fans in the writer's room. It even evolved to a situation where we had chopsticks hanging around the room from take out, you know, we ate a lot of our meals in the writer's room.
Yeah. What was up with the Harry Potter thing? Yeah, I was so curious. I was like, was this like an inside joke in the writer's room? And this is what Jen had to say. We had a bunch of Harry Potter fans in the writer's room. It even evolved to a situation where we had chopsticks hanging around the room from take out, you know, we ate a lot of our meals in the writer's room.|||是啊。那个《哈利·波特》是怎么回事？对，我当时太好奇了。我在想，这难道是编剧室里的内部笑话吗？简是这么说的：我们在编剧室里有一堆《哈利·波特》迷。它甚至发展到这种地步：我们的房间里挂满了外卖的筷子，你知道的，我们的很多饭都在编剧室里吃。
And so one afternoon, we decorated our chopsticks while we were probably pitching stories and jokes. We each decorated chopsticks. And then we had, we were pretending that they were Harry Potter wands and we would do spells on each other, probably just comedy spells. But we even had wand stands near the writer's room door that were just little thumbtacks, you know, spread apart so that we would rest our wands on them. So everybody had their Harry Potter chopstick wands and our wand stands.
And so one afternoon, we decorated our chopsticks while we were probably pitching stories and jokes. We each decorated chopsticks. And then we had, we were pretending that they were Harry Potter wands and we would do spells on each other, probably just comedy spells. But we even had wand stands near the writer's room door that were just little thumbtacks, you know, spread apart so that we would rest our wands on them. So everybody had their Harry Potter chopstick wands and our wand stands.|||所以在某天下午，我们一边构思故事和笑话，一边装饰我们的筷子。我们每个人都装饰了筷子。然后我们假装它们是哈利·波特的魔杖，我们会互相施咒，大概只是搞笑的咒语。但我们甚至在编剧室门附近放了魔杖架，那只是一些小图钉，你知道的，隔开一段距离，这样我们就可以把魔杖搁在上面。所以每个人都有自己的哈利·波特筷子魔杖和我们的魔杖架。
And that sounds super dorky. And I believe it is. It was really fun. Once again, what the writers were doing to procrastinate made it into a script. Yeah, I feel like there's probably more of that than we will ever know. Yes, exactly. All right. So at seven minutes, six seconds, Michael has his big survivor speech.
And that sounds super dorky. And I believe it is. It was really fun. Once again, what the writers were doing to procrastinate made it into a script. Yeah, I feel like there's probably more of that than we will ever know. Yes, exactly. All right. So at seven minutes, six seconds, Michael has his big survivor speech.|||这听起来超级书呆子气。我相信它确实如此。真的非常有趣。又一次，编剧们用来拖延时间的恶作剧竟然写进了剧本里。是的，我觉得这样的事情可能比我们想象的还要多。确实如此。好吧。所以在 7 分 06 秒时，迈克尔发表了他的大型《幸存者》演讲。
Now you guys, we've shared this before, but our camera operators, Randall and Matt, both worked on Survivor. So this had been a little bit of an interesting callback for them, right, Jenna? Well, yes. And how prepared were they to lug cameras on their shoulders on a beach? I mean, these guys, they were like, oh, I've come full circle. Yeah, bring it. So Michael says this, a group of Americans will undergo the ultimate challenge.
Now you guys, we've shared this before, but our camera operators, Randall and Matt, both worked on Survivor. So this had been a little bit of an interesting callback for them, right, Jenna? Well, yes. And how prepared were they to lug cameras on their shoulders on a beach? I mean, these guys, they were like, oh, I've come full circle. Yeah, bring it. So Michael says this, a group of Americans will undergo the ultimate challenge.|||好了各位，我们以前分享过这个，但我们的摄像师兰德尔（Randall）和马特（Matt）都曾在《幸存者》节目组工作过。所以这对他们来说算是一个挺有趣的回应，对吧，珍娜？嗯，是的。他们对扛着摄像机在海滩上奔波有多大准备？我的意思是，这两个家伙当时的想法是：“哦，我的人生又转回原点啦。”是的，放马过来吧。所以迈克尔说了这样的话：一群美国人将经历终极挑战。
One day, 14 strangers who worked together, but only one survivor. And they're all like, what? What's about to happen here? Well, what's about to happen is a spoon and egg race, Angela. Oh, yeah. Except the person with the egg will be blindfolded. Also, Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but poor Brian, they had him in the background.
One day, 14 strangers who worked together, but only one survivor. And they're all like, what? What's about to happen here? Well, what's about to happen is a spoon and egg race, Angela. Oh, yeah. Except the person with the egg will be blindfolded. Also, Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but poor Brian, they had him in the background.|||一天时间，14个在一起共事的陌生人，但最终只能有一个幸存者。他们都一脸懵：什么？这里要发生什么？嗯，接下来要发生的是勺子运鸡蛋比赛，安吉拉。哦，是的。只不过拿鸡蛋的那个人会被蒙上双眼。另外，珍娜，我不知道你还记不记得，可怜的布莱恩，他们安排他在背景里。
He's just eating his egg. He's eating and it didn't make it on camera. And I remember feeling so bad that Brian in the course of this time in the heat had to eat hard-boiled eggs and hot dogs. I was like, this poor guy. And also, I think it's very funny that Michael hard-boiled the eggs. Yes. Because then if they fall off the spoon, it doesn't matter.
He's just eating his egg. He's eating and it didn't make it on camera. And I remember feeling so bad that Brian in the course of this time in the heat had to eat hard-boiled eggs and hot dogs. I was like, this poor guy. And also, I think it's very funny that Michael hard-boiled the eggs. Yes. Because then if they fall off the spoon, it doesn't matter.|||他一直在吃他的鸡蛋。他一直在吃，但这并没有被拍进镜头里。我记得当时觉得布莱恩太惨了，在这段酷热难耐的时间里，他不得不吃水煮蛋和热狗。我想：这个可怜的家伙。而且，我觉得迈克尔把鸡蛋煮熟了这一行为非常搞笑。是的。因为这样一来，如果它们从勺子上掉下来也没关系。
There's no point. There's no point. Now, I am wondering, and I don't know the answer, I am speculating, but I wonder if we had to hard-boil the eggs because we couldn't risk having eggs break on the beach and sort of leaving behind that kind of debris, because when we left there, we had to make it seem like we'd never been there at all. Not only that, but there's no way we could be dealing with wardrobe issues with egg yolk.
There's no point. There's no point. Now, I am wondering, and I don't know the answer, I am speculating, but I wonder if we had to hard-boil the eggs because we couldn't risk having eggs break on the beach and sort of leaving behind that kind of debris, because when we left there, we had to make it seem like we'd never been there at all. Not only that, but there's no way we could be dealing with wardrobe issues with egg yolk.|||那就毫无意义了。毫无意义。现在，我在想，我也不知道答案，我只是在推测，我在想我们是不是必须把鸡蛋煮熟，因为我们冒不起鸡蛋在海滩上破裂并留下那种残渣的风险，因为当我们离开那里时，我们必须表现得好像我们根本没去过那里一样。不仅如此，我们绝不可能处理由于蛋黄引起的服装问题。
Yes, exactly. But I like to think that it was just Michael's strange choice, but it was probably a very, very practical one. Oh, I'm sure it was very thought out. I wrote, what the heck? Who was setting up these teakie torches? Where did the blindfolds come in? Who carried the eggs?
Yes, exactly. But I like to think that it was just Michael's strange choice, but it was probably a very, very practical one. Oh, I'm sure it was very thought out. I wrote, what the heck? Who was setting up these teakie torches? Where did the blindfolds come in? Who carried the eggs?|||是的，完全如此。但我愿意认为这只是迈克尔古怪的选择，不过这可能是一个非常非常务实的选择。哦，我确信这是经过深思熟虑的。我写道：搞什么鬼？谁在竖起这些提基火炬？眼罩是从哪儿来的？谁带了鸡蛋？
Who had the spoons? What is happening? Oh, Angela, I don't know if it's in the deleted scenes, but in the script, there was an extra scene where Dwight discovers these boxes of supplies that Michael has packed in the back of the bus. And he's trying to get Michael to tell him what they are. What are the torches for? What is this for, Michael?
Who had the spoons? What is happening? Oh, Angela, I don't know if it's in the deleted scenes, but in the script, there was an extra scene where Dwight discovers these boxes of supplies that Michael has packed in the back of the bus. And he's trying to get Michael to tell him what they are. What are the torches for? What is this for, Michael?|||谁拿了勺子？这到底是怎么回事？哦，安吉拉，我不知道这是否在删减片段里，但在剧本中，有一个额外的场景：德怀特发现了迈克尔塞在巴士后座上的这些补给箱。他试图让迈克尔告诉他这些是什么。火炬是用来干什么的？迈克尔，这又是干什么用的？
And Michael's like, stop badgering me. That is in the deleted scenes, but it's just a bag where he's trying to zip up and Dwight's like, is that a sumo suit? Are we going to do Japanese business exercises? But none of the other supplies are seen. And I guess my whole point is, fine, fine, Jenna, he had the supplies on the back of the bus. Who's setting them up?
And Michael's like, stop badgering me. That is in the deleted scenes, but it's just a bag where he's trying to zip up and Dwight's like, is that a sumo suit? Are we going to do Japanese business exercises? But none of the other supplies are seen. And I guess my whole point is, fine, fine, Jenna, he had the supplies on the back of the bus. Who's setting them up?|||迈克尔则说：别再烦我了。这确实在删减片段里，但那只是一个他正试图拉上拉链的袋子，德怀特说：那是相扑服吗？我们要去进行日本商务锻炼吗？但其他补给品都没出现。我想我整个人的重点是：好吧，好吧，珍娜，他在巴士后座备了这些补给。是谁在把它们摆好设定的？
Where's my B-roll footage of Dwight having to run around and stab teakie torches in the ground? Well, I know I'm jumping ahead, but later we're going to see two guys setting a giant fire pit thing. With a red pickup truck, who are these dudes? I guess. I don't know. Michael had some assistance.
Where's my B-roll footage of Dwight having to run around and stab teakie torches in the ground? Well, I know I'm jumping ahead, but later we're going to see two guys setting a giant fire pit thing. With a red pickup truck, who are these dudes? I guess. I don't know. Michael had some assistance.|||我的德怀特不得不跑来跑去把提基火炬插在泥土里的花絮镜头在哪里？好吧，我知道我扯远了，但稍后我们会看到两个家伙在搭建一个巨大的火坑装置。开着一辆红色的皮卡车，这些家伙是谁？我猜。我不知道。迈克尔得到了一些协助。
Okay. We just have to suspend belief a little bit, guys. I guess so. Well, during this egg race, at nine minutes, 54 seconds, you can fully see Mindy starting to laugh. Oh, yeah. When Ed is yelling at her, when she's afraid she's going to run into the big rock, she starts laughing.
Okay. We just have to suspend belief a little bit, guys. I guess so. Well, during this egg race, at nine minutes, 54 seconds, you can fully see Mindy starting to laugh. Oh, yeah. When Ed is yelling at her, when she's afraid she's going to run into the big rock, she starts laughing.|||好吧。大家只需稍微暂停一下理性思维就行了。我想是的。嗯，在这场鸡蛋比赛中，在 9 分 54 秒时，你可以清楚地看到敏迪开始笑了。哦，是的。当埃德对她大喊大叫时，当她害怕自己会撞上那块大石头时，她笑了起来。
Yes. And I personally love how Ryan says to Dwight, if you keep shouting at me, I'm going to stop. I'm going to stop this race. And he doesn't stop shouting, so he just takes off his blindfold and throws his spoon on the ground. Now, Jenna, I think there's a portion of that scene that was on the fly kind of scene, and that was improvised dialogue between BJ and Rain.
Yes. And I personally love how Ryan says to Dwight, if you keep shouting at me, I'm going to stop. I'm going to stop this race. And he doesn't stop shouting, so he just takes off his blindfold and throws his spoon on the ground. Now, Jenna, I think there's a portion of that scene that was on the fly kind of scene, and that was improvised dialogue between BJ and Rain.|||是的。我个人非常喜欢瑞恩对德怀特说的话：如果你继续对我大吼大叫，我就不干了。我要终止这场比赛。而德怀特没有停止大喊大叫，于是瑞恩直接摘下眼罩，把勺子扔在了地上。现在，珍娜，我觉得那一幕有一部分是临场发挥的那种场景，那是 BJ 和雷恩之间即兴发挥的对话。
That's what they talked about in the DVD commentary. Do you remember that? Yes. Yes. That's right. In the walking head, where we see that she's taking her diligent notes, and we had some fan questions from Lily S, Ashley Hildreth, and Madison Barton. Jenna, did you really write the notes?
That's what they talked about in the DVD commentary. Do you remember that? Yes. Yes. That's right. In the walking head, where we see that she's taking her diligent notes, and we had some fan questions from Lily S, Ashley Hildreth, and Madison Barton. Jenna, did you really write the notes?|||这就是他们在 DVD 评论音轨里谈论的内容。你还记得吗？是的。是的。没错。在那个移动访谈（walking head）中，我们看到她正在认真记笔记，我们收到了来自莉莉·S（Lily S）、阿什利·希尔德雷思（Ashley Hildreth）和麦迪逊·巴顿（Madison Barton）的粉丝提问。珍娜，你真的写了笔记吗？
And if so, what did you write? I'm with you. I want to know, too. I'm like, I know my BFF, and I'm guessing you actually were writing things down. What were you doing? I was taking diligent notes. I knew it. I knew it.
And if so, what did you write? I'm with you. I want to know, too. I'm like, I know my BFF, and I'm guessing you actually were writing things down. What were you doing? I was taking diligent notes. I knew it. I knew it.|||如果是的话，你都写了些什么？我和你一样。我也想知道。我想：我了解我的闺蜜，我猜你当时确实在写东西。你当时在干什么？我在认真记笔记。我就知道。我就知道。
In character. Yeah. So there's a moment where I hold up my notebook, and I tried to freeze on it to see if I could copy down what it said, and it was too fuzzy. But you can see that I am writing. You know, Dwight did this, Dwight did that, Jim did this. I thought that the best way to get through those scenes was to actually write down what was happening around me, as if I was in character.
In character. Yeah. So there's a moment where I hold up my notebook, and I tried to freeze on it to see if I could copy down what it said, and it was too fuzzy. But you can see that I am writing. You know, Dwight did this, Dwight did that, Jim did this. I thought that the best way to get through those scenes was to actually write down what was happening around me, as if I was in character.|||完全是以角色的身份。对。所以有一个时刻我举起了笔记本，我试图在画面暂停时看看能不能抄下上面写的内容，但太模糊了。但你能看出我确实在写字。你知道的，德怀特做了这个，德怀特做了那个，吉姆做了那个。我当时觉得熬过那些场景的最好方法就是把周围发生的事情真正记录下来，就像我真的身处角色中一样。
I figured you were. So you can see Michael is losing people. Like Stanley is so happy Phil has dropped the egg. He's going to go sit down. He's going to do his crossword on his lawn chair. Creed wonders off, and in the background, we see him catch a fish with his bare hands. Yeah. Well, there's a really fun little tidbit about that on the DVD commentary.
I figured you were. So you can see Michael is losing people. Like Stanley is so happy Phil has dropped the egg. He's going to go sit down. He's going to do his crossword on his lawn chair. Creed wonders off, and in the background, we see him catch a fish with his bare hands. Yeah. Well, there's a really fun little tidbit about that on the DVD commentary.|||我猜你就是这样的。所以你可以看到迈克尔正在失去对大家的控制。比如斯坦利看到菲尔把鸡蛋掉了，高兴得不得了。他要去坐下来了。他要在他的草坪椅上做填字游戏。克里德闲逛走开了，在背景里，我们看到他空手抓到了一条鱼。对。嗯，DVD 评论音轨里有一个关于这个的非常有趣的小花絮。
Harold said, you guys, this is how we did it. There was a rubber fish that they sort of submerged like in a bucket. What you can't see is this rubber fish in water in a bucket, and they really were able to cheat it because Creed's a little bit over the hill, you know? Yeah. And he reaches down real fast, and he pulls it out, but I thought Creed did a great job of selling that. That was some good hand acting.
Harold said, you guys, this is how we did it. There was a rubber fish that they sort of submerged like in a bucket. What you can't see is this rubber fish in water in a bucket, and they really were able to cheat it because Creed's a little bit over the hill, you know? Yeah. And he reaches down real fast, and he pulls it out, but I thought Creed did a great job of selling that. That was some good hand acting.|||哈罗德说：伙计们，我们是这么拍的。有一条橡胶鱼，他们把它浸在类似水桶的东西里。你所看不到的是水桶里水中的这条橡胶鱼，他们真的能够作弊，因为克里德年纪有点大了，你知道的？对。他飞快地把手伸下去，然后把它拔了出来，但我认为克里德把这幕演得棒极了。那真是一段精彩的手部演技。
It was. And Harold said, true to Hollywood form, this gag, that rubber fish cost $500. Well, here's an interesting tidbit. Fishing is not allowed on Lake Scranton. Oh, that's true. But maybe if you're Creed and you grab it with your bare hands. Well, you know what that scene reminded me of, Angela? What?
It was. And Harold said, true to Hollywood form, this gag, that rubber fish cost $500. Well, here's an interesting tidbit. Fishing is not allowed on Lake Scranton. Oh, that's true. But maybe if you're Creed and you grab it with your bare hands. Well, you know what that scene reminded me of, Angela? What?|||确实如此。哈罗德还说，不愧是好莱坞风格，这个小桥段——那条橡胶鱼花了 500 美元。嗯，这里有个有趣的花絮。斯克兰顿湖是不允许钓鱼的。哦，也是。但如果你是克里德，而且你是用双手直接抓的。嗯，你知道那个场景让我想起了什么吗，安吉拉？什么？
The edge. Oh, good lord. The edge. Having to just get the fish. You got to. I mean, I don't know if anyone actually catches a fish with their hand in the edge, but I mean, that's survival. Maybe the bear did.
The edge. Oh, good lord. The edge. Having to just get the fish. You got to. I mean, I don't know if anyone actually catches a fish with their hand in the edge, but I mean, that's survival. Maybe the bear did.|||《边缘》（The Edge）。哦，天哪。《边缘》。非得去弄到那条鱼不可。你必须得这么做。我的意思是，我不知道是否有人真的在《边缘》里用手抓到过鱼，但我的意思是，那就是求生。也许那头熊抓到了。
The bear did. Oh, I won't bring up the bear. I know it's, I know it's a trigger for you. I really think you need to watch the series alone about the survivalist in the woods, because that's what it made me think of now. Maybe I should. Okay. I'm currently really obsessed with The Chef Show.
The bear did. Oh, I won't bring up the bear. I know it's, I know it's a trigger for you. I really think you need to watch the series alone about the survivalist in the woods, because that's what it made me think of now. Maybe I should. Okay. I'm currently really obsessed with The Chef Show.|||熊确实抓到了。哦，我不提那头熊了。我知道那是、我知道那是你的敏感点。我真的觉得你应该独自看那部关于森林求生专家的剧集，因为那就是它现在让我想到的东西。也许我应该看。好吧。我最近真的迷上了《落魄大厨秀》（The Chef Show）。
The Chef Show. The Chef Show. Okay, so John Favreau, who incidentally directed an episode of The Office in season nine, will get to it. Yeah. He has this movie called Chef, and it's so good. Came out several years ago. It's one of my favorite movies.
The Chef Show. The Chef Show. Okay, so John Favreau, who incidentally directed an episode of The Office in season nine, will get to it. Yeah. He has this movie called Chef, and it's so good. Came out several years ago. It's one of my favorite movies.|||《落魄大厨秀》。《落魄大厨秀》。好吧，乔恩·费儒（John Favreau）——顺便说一句，他在第九季中执导过一集《办公室》，我们以后会聊到。是的。他有一部电影叫《落魄大厨》（Chef），非常棒。几年前上映的。这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
Well, he is obsessed with bread baking and cooking. And so he has started this series called The Chef Show, where he goes and he interviews different chefs while they make their signature dishes. I can't get enough of it. You must love it. Now, this is a total tangent, but Isabel and I love the greatest British bakeoff. We love it so much, and it checks off all my boxes. It's like in the beautiful English countryside, and I just love everything, especially when
Well, he is obsessed with bread baking and cooking. And so he has started this series called The Chef Show, where he goes and he interviews different chefs while they make their signature dishes. I can't get enough of it. You must love it. Now, this is a total tangent, but Isabel and I love the greatest British bakeoff. We love it so much, and it checks off all my boxes. It's like in the beautiful English countryside, and I just love everything, especially when|||嗯，他痴迷于烤面包和烹饪。所以他开办了这个名为《落魄大厨秀》的系列节目，在节目中他去采访不同的厨师，同时看他们制作拿手菜。我简直看不够。你一定会喜欢它的。现在，这完全扯远了，但伊莎贝尔和我非常喜欢《英大烘焙大赛》（The Great British Baking Show）。我们太喜欢了，它完全符合我的所有喜好。它就像是在美丽的英国乡间，我喜欢里面的一切，尤其是当……
things don't go well. They'll say, like, it's a bit of a disaster, wasn't it? Yes, quite for the poet, yeah. I know. So matter of fact. I love that show as well. That show is the show that got me to start making bread. Oh, I didn't know that.
things don't go well. They'll say, like, it's a bit of a disaster, wasn't it? Yes, quite for the poet, yeah. I know. So matter of fact. I love that show as well. That show is the show that got me to start making bread. Oh, I didn't know that.|||事情进展不顺利的时候。他们会说，比如“这有点像场灾难，不是吗？”是的，对那个诗人来说确实如此，对。我知道。太实事求是了。我也很喜欢那个节目。那个节目就是让我开始学做面包的契机。哦，我以前不知道这个。
Yeah. Yeah, that's my bread origin story. My gosh, we are very off topic, and we have a lot to cover. We've got to get to this hot dog eating contest. Let's do it. We have a scene. Michael comes up to Pam and hands her 800 hot dogs that she needs to have ready in 10 minutes.
Yeah. Yeah, that's my bread origin story. My gosh, we are very off topic, and we have a lot to cover. We've got to get to this hot dog eating contest. Let's do it. We have a scene. Michael comes up to Pam and hands her 800 hot dogs that she needs to have ready in 10 minutes.|||对。是的，这就是我的面包起源故事。天哪，我们扯得太远了，我们还有很多内容要讲。我们得讲到这个热狗大胃王比赛了。开始吧。我们有一个场景。迈克尔走到潘面前，递给她 800 个热狗，要求她在 10 分钟内准备好。
What was Michael's budget for this day? I don't know. Where did he get the money for this? Just the 800 hot dogs alone. I know. How much does that cost? Can someone do some math on that 800 hot dogs? I need to know how much money Michael spent on hot dogs.
What was Michael's budget for this day? I don't know. Where did he get the money for this? Just the 800 hot dogs alone. I know. How much does that cost? Can someone do some math on that 800 hot dogs? I need to know how much money Michael spent on hot dogs.|||迈克尔这天的预算是多少？我不知道。他从哪儿弄来的钱买这些？光是这 800 个热狗。我知道。这得花多少钱？谁能帮这 800 个热狗算算账？我需要知道迈克尔在热狗上花了多少钱。
Well also during that scene, and this is slightly off topic, but also not, we got some mail about it at 11 minutes, 27 seconds. You can see my bra strap. And a lot of people wanted to know, why am I wearing a bra and a bathing suit? So here are my layers for the day, guys. I had on a bra, because I like wearing them. That's why I have a bra on, because I didn't want to wear just a flimsy swimming suit top. I like some support.
Well also during that scene, and this is slightly off topic, but also not, we got some mail about it at 11 minutes, 27 seconds. You can see my bra strap. And a lot of people wanted to know, why am I wearing a bra and a bathing suit? So here are my layers for the day, guys. I had on a bra, because I like wearing them. That's why I have a bra on, because I didn't want to wear just a flimsy swimming suit top. I like some support.|||嗯，还有在那个场景中，这稍微有点题外话，但也不完全算，我们在 11 分 27 秒时收到了一些关于它的邮件。你能看到我的内衣肩带。很多人想知道，我为什么既穿着内衣又穿着泳衣？所以，伙计们，以下是我当天的穿搭层次。我穿着内衣，因为我喜欢穿。这就是为什么我穿着内衣，因为我不想只穿一件单薄的泳衣上衣。我喜欢有一点支撑力。
On top of the bra, I'm wearing my wardrobe swimming suit top, which I loved, because Carrie Bennett, she came up with this idea that if it was like a halter suit, we would get an indication of a bathing suit, even though you never see me in the bathing suit. I thought it was a great idea. Then I have on a tank top, and the reason I'm wearing the tank top is to cover up the bra strap. We had a little bit of a fail here at 11 minutes, 27 seconds. And then I'm wearing a hoodie.
On top of the bra, I'm wearing my wardrobe swimming suit top, which I loved, because Carrie Bennett, she came up with this idea that if it was like a halter suit, we would get an indication of a bathing suit, even though you never see me in the bathing suit. I thought it was a great idea. Then I have on a tank top, and the reason I'm wearing the tank top is to cover up the bra strap. We had a little bit of a fail here at 11 minutes, 27 seconds. And then I'm wearing a hoodie.|||在内衣外面，我穿着服装组准备的泳衣上衣，我很喜欢它，因为凯丽·贝内特（Carrie Bennett）想出了这样一个主意：如果它是一件挂脖泳衣，我们就能暗示这是一套泳衣，尽管你从头到尾也没见我穿过这套泳衣。我觉得这是个绝妙的主意。然后我穿了一件背心，我穿背心的原因是为了遮住内衣肩带。我们在 11 分 27 秒这里出现了一点小失误。然后我还穿了一件连帽衫。
Those were my layers. So I guess somehow Pam cooked these hot dogs. I mean, she has a glance to camera where she's like, I don't know, maybe I didn't cook them. There is a deleted scene between Pam and Michael, where she is grilling the hot dogs, and he comes over and he's like, speed it up, Pam. Why aren't these done yet? And you're like, because there's 800 of them. Amazing.
Those were my layers. So I guess somehow Pam cooked these hot dogs. I mean, she has a glance to camera where she's like, I don't know, maybe I didn't cook them. There is a deleted scene between Pam and Michael, where she is grilling the hot dogs, and he comes over and he's like, speed it up, Pam. Why aren't these done yet? And you're like, because there's 800 of them. Amazing.|||这些就是我的层叠穿搭。所以我想潘不知怎么地就把这些热狗给做好了。我的意思是，她朝镜头看了一眼，那表情好像在说：我不知道，也许我根本没做熟它们。在潘和迈克尔之间有一个被删减的场景，她在烤热狗，迈克尔走过来对她说：快一点，潘。为什么还没做好？而你的反应是：因为这里有 800 个。太绝了。
Amazing. So now it's time for the big hot dog eating contest, where by the way, Michael takes credit for cooking up the hot dogs. I know. I know. And there is a wonderful deleted scene, Jenna. It wasn't scripted. It was a collective improv moment when Michael says, dip it in the water so it will slide
Amazing. So now it's time for the big hot dog eating contest, where by the way, Michael takes credit for cooking up the hot dogs. I know. I know. And there is a wonderful deleted scene, Jenna. It wasn't scripted. It was a collective improv moment when Michael says, dip it in the water so it will slide|||太棒了。现在是盛大的热狗大胃王比赛时间了，顺便说一句，迈克尔居然把烤热狗的功劳揽到了自己身上。我知道。我懂。珍娜，有一个非常精彩的删减片段。那不是剧本里的。那是大家集体即兴发挥的时刻，当迈克尔说“把它沾一下水，这样它就会……”
down your gullet more easily. Our whole table said, that's what she said. I remember that. And it didn't make it in, but it's so good. That's because that line from Steve was an improvisation. He in the script, he yells at Phyllis, dip it in the water, dip it in the water. But that's all that was scripted. So Steve in the moment added the so it'll slide down your gullet faster.
down your gullet more easily. Our whole table said, that's what she said. I remember that. And it didn't make it in, but it's so good. That's because that line from Steve was an improvisation. He in the script, he yells at Phyllis, dip it in the water, dip it in the water. But that's all that was scripted. So Steve in the moment added the so it'll slide down your gullet faster.|||更容易滑进你的喉咙里。我们整张桌子的人都说：“她刚才就是这么说的。”我记得那个。虽然它没能剪进正片里，但真的太棒了。那是因为史蒂夫的这句台词是即兴发挥的。他在剧本里是对菲利斯大喊：把它沾点水，把它沾点水。但剧本里只有这些。所以史蒂夫当时临时加了一句：“这样它滑进你喉咙里会更快。”
And then we all, I mean, how can you not? How can you not? How can you not? That was a layup. No, that was a softball. Isn't a layup and a softball sort of the same idea? I don't know. A layup?
And then we all, I mean, how can you not? How can you not? How can you not? That was a layup. No, that was a softball. Isn't a layup and a softball sort of the same idea? I don't know. A layup?|||然后我们所有人都……我的意思是，怎么能不接梗呢？怎么能不接？怎么能不接？那简直是个十拿九稳的得分机会。不，那是个“简单得不能再简单的问题（softball）”。上篮（layup）和抛球/简单问题（softball）难道不是差不多的意思吗？我不知道。上篮？
After I've thought about it, I'm going to give this to softball because a softball involves more than one person, right? Yeah. So softball, one person sends a softball to another who then hits it out of the park. Whereas with a layup, it's you do it on your own. You do it on your own. And I mean, a layup through a crowd is not easy to do. If there's a bunch of guys in the paint, let me throw some basketball at you.
After I've thought about it, I'm going to give this to softball because a softball involves more than one person, right? Yeah. So softball, one person sends a softball to another who then hits it out of the park. Whereas with a layup, it's you do it on your own. You do it on your own. And I mean, a layup through a crowd is not easy to do. If there's a bunch of guys in the paint, let me throw some basketball at you.|||等我想了想之后，我决定把这个归类为“简单问题（softball）”，因为垒球（softball）涉及不止一个人，对吧？对。所以垒球是，一个人把垒球投给另一个人，然后由那个人把它击出场外。而上篮呢，则是你自己一个人完成的。你自己一个人完成。我的意思是，在人群中强行上篮可不容易。如果禁区里有一堆大汉，让我来给你讲点篮球战术吧。
But maybe if you got it, maybe if you think a layup is if you hold on a second, hold on a second. When's the last time you did a layup? I did one this week. What is it to you? A layup is when you dribble up to the basket and you put it in on your own. But I'm telling you, if you're doing a layup, you know, and you're, if you're doing a layup and you're being guarded, but then there's the breakaway layup, right?
But maybe if you got it, maybe if you think a layup is if you hold on a second, hold on a second. When's the last time you did a layup? I did one this week. What is it to you? A layup is when you dribble up to the basket and you put it in on your own. But I'm telling you, if you're doing a layup, you know, and you're, if you're doing a layup and you're being guarded, but then there's the breakaway layup, right?|||但也许如果你懂的话，也许如果你认为上篮是……等一下，等一下。你上一次上篮是什么时候？我这周刚做过一次。这对于你来说算什么？上篮就是当你运球冲向篮筐然后自己把球放进去。但我告诉你，如果你在做上篮，你知道的，如果你在做上篮时有人防守，但还有一种是快攻单刀上篮（breakaway layup），对吧？
If you steal the ball and you got the whole back of the court to yourself and you're like, yeah. And you do your layup. And then sometimes you want to dunk on your layup. Hard for me because I'm five one. What's happening right now? I don't know. Where are we?
If you steal the ball and you got the whole back of the court to yourself and you're like, yeah. And you do your layup. And then sometimes you want to dunk on your layup. Hard for me because I'm five one. What's happening right now? I don't know. Where are we?|||如果你断了球，整个后场只有你一个人，然后你心里想：太棒了。然后你完成上篮。有时候你还想在上篮的时候顺便扣个篮。这对我来说太难了，因为我身高只有五尺一寸（约 155 厘米）。现在到底是什么情况？我不知道。我们这是在哪儿？
What is what? Wait, do you watch basketball? Are you like a basketball fan? Where's all this lingo coming from? I play basketball. I played JV. And then when everyone got really tall, I had to stop playing because I was too short. And we had a really good point guard.
What is what? Wait, do you watch basketball? Are you like a basketball fan? Where's all this lingo coming from? I play basketball. I played JV. And then when everyone got really tall, I had to stop playing because I was too short. And we had a really good point guard.|||什么是什么？等等，你看篮球吗？你是个篮球迷吗？这些行话都是从哪儿学来的？我打篮球。我打过校二队（JV）。然后当所有人都变得很高大时，我不得不停止打球，因为我太矮了。而且我们当时有一个非常优秀的控球后卫。
So then I became a basketball cheerleader. And I was also the manager on the basketball team. And I was also a mascot one basketball season. And I love basketball and we have a hoop in our driveway and we play all the time. And I have a fantastic outside shot. And I often win at horse. Angela, I'm clapping because people couldn't see me bowing down to you. But I mean, I'm speechless.
所以后来我成了篮球啦啦队队员。我还是篮球队的经理。有一个篮球赛季我还当过吉祥物。我非常喜欢篮球，我们的车道上就有一个篮筐，我们经常玩。而且我的远投很厉害。我玩“马”字投篮游戏经常赢。安吉拉，我这是在鼓掌，因为大家看不到我在向你鞠躬。不过我是说，我都说不出话来了。
I did not know this about you. And also, I mean, I defer to you here. If this were a debate and someone had to win, you won. I mean, that was just. I want you to know it's not out yet, but I have this Advil commercial where I have to shoot baskets and I made like 13 baskets in a row. And one of them they used in the actual shot. And I was so happy that they showed the whole shot because I was like, I made that sucker.
我以前不知道你还有这技能。而且，我的意思是，在这方面我甘拜下风。如果这是一场辩论，必须得有人赢的话，那你赢了。我是说，这真是……我想让你们知道，虽然还没播出，但我拍过一个雅维斯的广告，里面我得投篮，我连续投进了大约13个球。其中一个还被用在了正片里。我当时特别高兴，因为他们播出了我整段投篮的画面，我想说：“那个球可是我投进的。”
You were Brian Baumgartner while shooting the basketball episode. You have like a secret basketball skill that no one knew about. Don't you remember the basketball hoop by our trailers and we would play horse? I was always out there with the guys playing horse. I do remember that. And I have a picture of it. Yeah. Well, listen, I feel like we've gone off topic.
你拍篮球那集的时候简直就是布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。你有一项谁都不知道的秘密篮球特技。你还记得我们房车旁边的那个篮球筐吗？我们会玩“马”字投篮？我总是和男生们一起在外面玩“马”字投篮。我确实记得。我还有一张照片呢。好吧，听着，我觉得我们有点跑题了。
I think, wait, we're back to the hot dogs guys, back to the hot dogs. Andy wins the competition, but this was an arduous scene for everyone to shoot. I was really lucky, Jenna, because I said my character is a vegetarian. She's not going to be eating these. I made a really big plea about that. But poor Brian and Ed Leslie, all those guys were shoving hot dogs in their face. Jenna, do you remember they were starting to gag? Do you remember that?
我觉得，等等，我们回正题，聊聊热狗，伙计们，聊回热狗。安迪赢了比赛，但对每个人来说，拍这场戏都相当不容易。詹娜，我真的很幸运，因为我说我的角色是个素食主义者。她才不吃这些东西呢。我为此极力请求过。但是可怜的布赖恩和埃德·莱斯利，所有那些家伙都得把热狗塞进嘴里。詹娜，你还记得他们开始干呕了吗？你记得吗？
Yeah. You know, we got a fan question from Caitlin Mulvihill who said, how many times did you have to film the hot dog contest scene and did you have to eat all the hot dogs every time? I just remember it took a long time. It was a lot of angles, a lot of coverage, a lot of reaction shots. We were there for like half a day. Yeah.
对。你知道的，我们收到了凯特琳·穆尔维希尔的一个粉丝提问，她说：你们拍热狗比赛那场戏拍了多少次？每次都得把热狗全都吃掉吗？我只记得这花了很长时间。有很多角度，很多机位，很多反应镜头。我们在那儿待了大半天吧。对。
But Jen, we asked Jen, what was the hardest stunt during beach games? And this is what she had to say. I think the answer for what was the hardest stunt of this episode depends on who you ask. I think for the actors, it was possibly the hot dog eating contest. I'm curious what you guys think. I remember spit buckets. I could be wrong about that, but I'm fairly certain there were a bunch of spit buckets. But there was some actual eating of hot dogs, and I think Ed Helms ate an enormous amount
但是詹，我们问过詹，海滩运动会期间最难的特技是什么？她是这么说的：我觉得这集最难的特技是什么，取决于你问的是谁。对于演员来说，可能就是吃热狗比赛了。我很想听听你们怎么想。我记得有吐痰桶。我可能记错了，但我相当确凿地记得有一堆吐痰桶。不过确实吃了一些热狗，而且我觉得埃德·海姆斯吃了惊人数量的
of hot dogs, if I remember correctly. I think he was going really hard for winning the contest. So I think that that was probably a lot of people's answers. For me, it was getting the shot during the Michael talking head of Andy floating away at sea. Yes. We will get to that. She sent in some more amazing stuff about that stunt, but I do remember the spit buckets,
热狗，如果我没记错的话。我觉得他为了赢得比赛真的是拼尽全力。所以我觉得这可能是很多人的答案。对我而言，最难的是拍迈克尔的单人镜头时，拍到安迪在海面上漂走的画面。没错。我们会聊到那部分的。她发了一些关于那个特技的更精彩的料，但我确实记得吐痰桶的事情，
Ange. I do too. And one of the things, you guys, on some shows, the way they shoot, you know when you're on camera, and when you're off camera, you don't have to sort of participate. You can kind of not eat, right? But the way we shot this, there was a huge group shot, right? There's a camera that's capturing everything. So these guys had to eat on every take, because they never knew when the camera was specifically
安吉。我也记得。而且其中有一点，伙计们，在某些节目中，他们拍摄的方式是，你知道自己什么时候在镜头前，当不在镜头前时，你就不太需要参与。你可以不吃东西，对吧？但我们拍摄的方式是，有一个超大的全景镜头，对吧？有一个镜头在捕捉一切。所以这些家伙每次拍摄都必须吃，因为他们永远不知道镜头具体什么时候
on them or not. And I remember when they would yell, cut, immediately, like the prop guys would run over with buckets, and these guys would all start spitting in the buckets, because they couldn't have the buckets on the ground. There was nowhere to hide them, right? Yeah. And so the prop guys would run over with the buckets, and Ed said this thing in the DVD commentary.
对准了他们。我记得当他们喊“停”的时候，道具人员马上就会拿着桶跑过来，这些人就会开始往桶里吐东西，因为他们不能把桶放在地上。没地方藏，对吧？对。所以道具人员会拿着桶跑过来，埃德在DVD评论音轨里说过这么一件事。
He said, first of all, spitting out food that I've been chewing and holding in my mouth, the action of spitting out this chewed food would activate my gag reflex. So I'd start gagging. And he said, but then on top of that, this bucket that they would bring around, several other people had spit their food out into, he said, just all of it. All of it, he said, like they were all getting so grossed out. Well, this scene really reminded me of that birthday cake scene from Meredith's birthday, where we all ate a chocolate chip ice cream cake.
他说，首先，把我已经咀嚼过并含在嘴里的食物吐出来，这个吐出咀嚼过食物的动作会触发我的呕吐反射。所以我就会开始干呕。他说，不仅如此，他们拿过来的这个桶里，好几个人都已经把食物吐进去了，他说，简直全都是。全都是，他说，搞得大家都很恶心。嗯，这场戏真的让我想起了梅雷迪思生日那场吃生日蛋糕的戏，我们当时一起吃了一个巧克力冰激凌蛋糕。
I can't eat it to this day. I can't eat it. Same. We ate so much of it because we never knew when we were on camera. And then like that, I feel like there's barely any footage in this episode of these guys eating the hot dogs. It does not accurately reflect how much hot dog eating happened. Not at all, these poor guys.
我直到今天都不能吃它。我吃不下。一样。我们吃了太多那个蛋糕，因为我们从不知道自己什么时候在镜头里。然后感觉这一集里几乎没有什么这些家伙吃热狗的镜头。这根本无法准确反映到底发生了多少吃热狗的量。完全没有，这些可怜的家伙。
And Jim isn't eating the hot dogs. There's a deleted scene where he brought a tuna salad, and he is not even participating. So John did not have to do this. And neither did I. And neither did Steve. Oh, God. Well, Jenna, so Andy wins with 13 hot dogs, right? Mm-hmm.
而且吉姆根本没吃热狗。有一个删减片段，他带了一份金枪鱼沙拉，他甚至都没有参与。所以约翰不需要做这件事。我也一样。史蒂夫也一样。天哪。好吧，詹娜，安迪以13个热狗赢了，对吧？嗯哼。
I just looked up this year, the hot dog eating contest, the Nathan's hot dog eating contest for 2020. Oh, lady. Did you too? Did you too? Because I've been to the hot dog eating contest. What? Yeah.
我刚刚查了一下今年的热狗大胃王比赛，2020年内森热狗大胃王比赛。哦，天哪。你也是吗？你也是吗？因为我去过热狗大胃王比赛。什么？对。
Win! In 2011. What? How? Why? I went to Coney Island. Lee and I were in New York. We were looking for something to do over July 4th weekend.
赢了！在2011年。什么？怎么回事？为什么？我去了科尼岛。莉和我在纽约。我们正在寻找国庆周末可以做的事情。
And you went to it? We saw that the Coney Island hot dog eating, we got on the subway and we rode it out there. I was very pregnant. I was like seven months pregnant. Oh, my gosh. I did not know any of this. See, you think you know your best friend. And then all of a sudden she's going to hot dog eating contests and she knows how to play
然后你去了？我们看到科尼岛热狗大胃王比赛的消息，就上了地铁坐了过去。我当时怀孕月份很大了。我大概怀孕七个月了。哦，天哪。我完全不知道这些。瞧，你以为你很了解你最好的朋友。结果突然之间她跑去看热狗大胃王比赛，而且她还会打
basketball. Yeah. Exactly. And I, here's my memory. It was super exciting. We only saw the men's contest. I saw Joey Chestnut win the hot dog eating contest. He won again this year.
篮球。对。没错。而且，这是我的记忆。这超级令人兴奋。我们只看了男子比赛。我看到乔伊·切斯特纳特赢得了热狗大胃王比赛。他今年又赢了。
Yeah. And he broke his world record this year. His nickname is Jaws. Joey Jaws Chestnut. Yeah. This year, because we both looked it up, Joey Chestnut ate 75 hot dogs and buns in 10 minutes. And Jenna in the female category, Miki Pseudo ate 48 and a half hot dogs in 10 minutes and now has the new world record.
对，而且他今年打破了自己的世界纪录。他的绰号是“大白鲨”。乔伊·“大白鲨”·切斯特纳特。是的。今年，因为我们俩都查了，乔伊·切斯特纳特在10分钟内吃掉了75个热狗和面包。而詹娜，在女子组中，须藤美贵在10分钟内吃掉了48个半热狗，现在创造了新的世界纪录。
Yeah. Joey Chestnut has won every year since 2007 with the exception of one year in 2015, Matt Stoney won. But Joey has won every year since. And Miki has won every year since 2014. I will say one thing. When I went to the hot dog eating contest, I mentioned I was very pregnant. I had to pee and there were no restrooms and all of the businesses because there's such
是的。自2007年以来，乔伊·切斯特纳特每年都赢得比赛，除了2015年马特·斯托尼赢过一次。但自那以后，乔伊每年都赢。而美贵自2014年以来每年都赢。我要说一件事。我去热狗大胃王比赛的时候，我提过我当时怀孕月份很大。我想上厕所，但没有洗手间，所有的商家都因为
a giant influx of people that come down. They all have signs that say no public restroom, no public restroom, no public restroom. You can't just go in and use their bathroom. But I found an employee at the Dunkin Donuts who's sneaked me in and let me use the bathroom there. Bless them. And I still to this day want to say thank you so much for helping me relieve my pregnant bladder that day.
涌入的人流实在太巨大了。他们都挂着牌子，写着“不提供公共洗手间，不提供公共洗手间，不提供公共洗手间”。你不能直接进去用他们的洗手间。但我找到了 Dunkin Donuts（唐恩都乐）的一名员工，他把我偷偷带进去，让我用了那里的洗手间。上帝保佑他们。直到今天，我仍然想说非常感谢你那天帮我排解了孕妇的膀胱压力。
Thank you nice person at Dunkin Donuts on Coney Island in 2011. You know, if you were Meredith, like the deleted scene, you would have just gone and squat in the bushes right by the bus. Oh no. Poor Kate. Kate in this episode, oh my God. Well, maybe Angela on that note, we should take a break here and both use the restroom. And then we'll come back with some sabotage sandwich.
谢谢2011年科尼岛Dunkin Donuts那位好心的人。你知道的，如果你是梅雷迪思，就像那个删减片段演的那样，你就会直接去公交车旁边的树丛里蹲着了。哦，不。可怜的凯特。这集里的凯特，天哪。好吧，安吉拉，顺着这个话题，我们在这里休息一下，都去上个洗手间。然后我们回来聊聊“破坏三明治”。
Now I said sandwich earlier this time I'm saying sabotage. Okay, we are back and oh, Angela, I love this scene so much. I rewound it and watched it twice. I do love this scene. It's one of my favorites. So this is the scene where Dwight and Angela have tiptoed away from the group and they're having a private conversation about sabotage Dwight would like Angela to sabotage her team. Yes, the ancient art, like Dutch sabotage, I was like, what?
刚才我说的明明是三明治，这次我说的是破坏。好吧，我们回来了，哦，安吉拉，我太喜欢这个场景了。我倒回去看了一遍又一遍。我也很喜欢这个场景。这是我最喜欢的场景之一。所以这是德怀特和安吉拉悄悄离开人群，正在私下讨论关于破坏的事情，德怀特希望安吉拉破坏她的团队。是的，古老的艺术，就像荷兰式的破坏，我当时想，什么？
This scene was so fun to film. First of all, I remember Jen and Harold and Rain and I trying to figure out where Dwight and I would be, it would really look like we were away from everyone. And also that we would think that we got away with it, right? Yes. And that the spy shot would have to be far enough away. So we did sort of climb, there were these little sand dunes, Jenna, do you remember? They were sort of small and they had like big sort of like tall kind of grass growing
拍这个场景太有趣了。首先，我记得詹、哈罗德、雷恩和我试图弄清楚德怀特和我应该站在哪里，才能真的看起来我们离所有人都很远。而且我们还得觉得我们成功摆脱了大家的视线，对吧？是的。而且偷拍的镜头必须足够远。所以我们确实爬了上去，那里有一些小沙丘，詹娜，你还记得吗？它们有点小，上面长着那种高高的草
out of them. Yeah, like reedy grass coming out of them. Itchy, itchy, reedy grass. Like it kind of like, it kind of cut you a little if it touched your skin. But we, we sort of tucked back in there for this scene and there are some great bloopers and it's mostly just me laughing because I could not get through it. When he said sabotage and I said sandwich every single time, the absurdity of these two, not to mention I could hear Jen Slotta laughing from her little group of bushes where
它们。对，就像那种从里面长出来的芦苇草。又刺又痒的芦苇草。如果你碰到它的话，它甚至会把你划破一点。不过为了这场戏，我们还是挤回了那里面，里面还有一些超棒的NG镜头，大部分其实都是我在笑，因为我根本没办法演下去。每当他说出“破坏”而我却说出“三明治”时，这两个人的荒谬感简直绝了，更不用说我还能听到简·斯洛塔在旁边的小灌木丛里笑的声音，当时
her and Harold were hiding and I would be like, Jen, stop laughing. I just got it together and now Jen is laughing and you couldn't see her. It was just like this little clump of bushes that was like, oh my gosh, I love it so much. I love the end when Dwight says if Michael organizes a group hug stand next to me. Jen told me she loved writing for Dwight and Angela that she loved their sort of suppressed love for one another. Yeah. Oh, it's such a good scene.
她和哈罗德正躲在那里，我就会说：“简，别笑了。我好不容易才进入状态，结果简又笑起来了。”而且你根本看不见她。那感觉就像是一小丛灌木在说：“哦天哪，我太喜欢了。”我特别喜欢结尾德怀特说的那句，如果迈克尔组织集体拥抱，一定要站在我旁边。简曾告诉我，她很喜欢为德怀特和安吉拉写台词，她喜欢他们那种对彼此压抑的爱意。天哪。哦，这真是一场好戏。
Such a good scene. One thing about the scene that made it tricky that you might not think of is that this is one of the few times where Dwight and I have to be standing facing one another and you really see our height difference. I knew it was a wide shot because it was a spy shot, but now it makes me think it was also that wide to fit you both in frame. Yes. And the other thing, the other thing to point out, which I thought was really great, is
真是一场好戏。关于这场戏有一个可能会让你意想不到的棘手之处，那就是这是少数几次我和德怀特必须面对面站着的时候，你会清楚地看到我们俩的身高差。我知道这是一个广角镜头，因为它是个偷拍镜头，但现在让我想起它之所以那么广，可能也是为了把你们两个都框进镜头里。没错。另外还有一件事，我觉得非常棒，那就是
you can really see that Dwight is wearing a Cooper Seafood T-shirt. Hey. Yeah. Little local Scranton reference there. I know. Well next up is the sumo competition. Oh my goodness, Jenna. Where to begin?
你能清楚地看到德怀特穿着一件库珀海鲜T恤。嘿。对，这里有个斯克兰顿当地的小彩梗。我知道。接下来就是相扑比赛了。哦天哪，珍娜。这从何说起呢？
Where to begin? Where to begin? I'll tell you, I did one of those like a guffaw. Is that the word where you laugh out loud like it takes over your body and you can't even suppress it? When I saw John in his little toothpick legs walk out in that sumo suit, look at his legs. If you haven't, look at his tiny little legs sticking out of that sumo suit and his little head popping up.
从何说起？从何说起？我跟你说，我当时发出了一种像“哈哈”大笑的声音。就是那种你笑出声来，甚至笑得全身失控都无法压抑的那种词吗？当我看到约翰穿着那套相扑服，迈着他那牙签般的小细腿走出来时，看看他的腿。如果你还没看过，一定要看看他从那套相扑服里伸出来的小细腿，还有他那冒出来的小脑袋。
It made me laugh so hard. Now I know that those guys were just so hot in those suits. Oh yeah. They were dying. And we had these little fans that they would try to like cool them off with, but I'm sure that they were just so sweaty, but they also had the best time in those. They were like, they all turned into children and they were loving it, I have to say. They couldn't wait to run at each other and like throw themselves at each other and all
把我笑得前仰后合。现在我知道那些家伙在那些衣服里简直快热死了。哦，是的。他们热得要命。我们有那种小风扇，他们会试图用它来给他们降温，但我敢肯定他们身上全是汗，不过他们在里面也玩得最开心。他们就像是一群变成了小孩的人，我得说他们太喜欢了。他们迫不及待地朝彼此冲过去，就像把自个儿扑向对方一样，还有
of it. They were having so much fun, but I do remember between takes, they could not sit down. Yes. They could not sit down and people would run over with like little umbrellas and these fans to try to cool them off. And Jenna, I was hanging out with Rain and I have this great photo that one of the things I loved is that I could lean on Rain's belly like I had something to prop myself up on. So I have this photo and it's him and I casually talking, but I'm resting myself on his sumo
所有那些。他们玩得太开心了，但我确实记得在拍摄间隙，他们根本坐不下来。是的。他们根本坐不下来，大家会拿着小雨伞和小风扇跑过来试图帮他们降温。珍娜，当时我和雷恩待在一起，我有一张超棒的照片，我最喜欢的一点就是我可以靠在雷恩的肚子上，就像有什么东西可以撑着我一样。所以我有了这样一张照片，画面里是我和他在随便聊天，但我整个人是靠在他的相扑
belly. That's incredible. Well, we had a fan question from Freya McKenzie and Jesse Magison. Is it true that Rain Wilson actually put Leslie David Baker in the hospital while shooting beach games? Yes. What happened was that during all this sumo wrestling, Leslie got sand in his eyes and they tried to flush it out, but they couldn't.
大肚子上的。太不可思议了。好吧，我们有一个来自弗雷娅·麦肯齐和杰西·马吉森的粉丝提问。雷恩·威尔逊在拍《海滩游戏》时真的把莱斯利·大卫·贝克送进医院了吗？是的。事情是这样的，在所有这些相扑摔跤的过程中，莱斯利眼睛里进了沙子，他们试图把它冲洗出来，但没能成功。
And I remember he had to leave set. And I don't know if he went to the hospital or to an eye doctor, but he had a scratched cornea. Yeah. I thought they took him to a local, like the clinic, the nearest hospital. Every single day when you're filming, whether it's on set or location, they put in the call sheet the location where you're filming and the nearest hospital's location. Yeah.
我记得他不得不离开片场。我不知道他是去了医院还是眼科医生那里，总之他的角膜被刮伤了。对。我还以为他们把他送到了当地的诊所，最近的医院呢。每天拍戏的时候，无论是在片场还是外景地，通告单上都会写明拍摄地点和最近的医院位置。对。
So they researched that ahead of time for this reason. So I think they took him to the nearest, whatever that was, clinic, right? Yeah. And he was in quite a bit of pain and he was like, no, it's still in there. There's something wrong. You know that moment in your body where you're like, it's not right. Something's not right. And it had, in fact, scratched his cornea and they treated him.
所以他们为了这个原因提前查好了。我想他们是把他送到了最近的诊所什么的，对吧？是的。而且他当时非常痛苦，一直在说：“不，它还在里面。有什么地方不对劲。”你知道那种身体发出的感觉，就是“这不对劲，有什么地方不对劲”。事实上，他的角膜确实被刮伤了，他们给他进行了治疗。
And then he came back and finished filming because he's such a trooper. Well, I've had this happen to me, Angela. I got a piece of sand in my eye by using a face scrub with sand in it. And I got a piece in my eye and I was like, it feels like something's in your eye when you scratch your cornea, but I couldn't find it. So I went to an eye doctor and I had scratched my cornea. So I, I feel for Leslie, it is a very, it is a not fun feeling. I have never scratched my cornea, but one time I was eating jalapeno potato chips because
然后他回来完成了拍摄，因为他太敬业了。好吧，安吉拉，我也遇到过这种情况。我用了带有磨砂颗粒的洗面奶，结果有一小块沙子进了我眼睛里。我眼睛里进了一块，我想：当你刮伤角膜时，感觉就像有什么东西在眼睛里一样，但我怎么也找不到。所以我去看眼科医生，发现我的角膜被刮伤了。所以，我非常理解莱斯利，那真是一种很不舒服的感觉。我从来没有刮伤过角膜，但有一次我在吃墨西哥胡椒味的薯片，因为
I love them so much. And I bit into it kind of aggressively and the jalapeno dust off the chip went into my eyes and it was very painful. Why are you laughing? This really happened. I bit into the chip and then I was like, why am I laughing? How could you listen to that story and not laugh at it? I don't know.
我太喜欢它们了。我咬得有点猛，薯片上的墨西哥胡椒粉末飞进我的眼睛里了，非常痛苦。你为什么在笑？这真的是发生过的事。我咬了一口薯片，然后我就想：我为什么在笑？你怎么能听到这个故事却不笑呢？我不知道。
I don't know. Okay. We should probably get back on topic. Yeah. Well, here's the thing. I remember Leslie leaving set, but I don't remember when exactly it happened or how it happened. I just know he got sand in his eye.
我不知道。好吧。我们大概该回到正题了。对。好吧，事情是这样的。我记得莱斯利离开了片场，但我记不清具体是什么时候发生的事情，也不知道它是怎么发生的。我只知道他眼睛里进了沙子。
All right. This is what I think happened. He watched the deleted scenes and there's a moment, it's not in the episode where Dwight is wrestling with Stanley and knocks him to the ground and is like, take that old man. And he kind of kicks at the sand, right? Oh, yes. I remember this. Yes.
好吧。我觉得事情是这样的。他看了被删减的片段，里面有一个镜头——正片里没有——德怀特和斯坦利摔跤，把他扑倒在地，然后说：“尝尝这个，老家伙。”他差不多还踢了踢沙子，对吧？哦，是的。我记得这个。是的。
And I think then rain felt really bad because he realized in that moment he, that's when he, that's when we thought it happened. Yes. That's right. Yeah. That's right. Well, this was not the only injury from this episode. Ed hurt his finger during the sumo wrestling.
然后我觉得雷恩当时一定觉得很糟糕，因为他意识到就是在那个时刻，那就是我们以为事情发生的时候。没错。就是这样。没错。好吧，这并不是本集唯一的受伤事件。埃德在相扑摔跤时伤了手指。
Do you remember that? I think he like lost a fingernail or something. He was like, sorry, it makes me laugh so hard. I shouldn't laugh. But it's when that moment, if you guys watch it, when Andy and Dwight really start going at each other, like Dwight walks over and he's eating a sandwich. Even though he's eating all these hot dogs, he walks over and then they just start going at each other and Ed is like kind of flailing his arms at him.
你还记得吗？我记得他好像指甲掉了一块什么的。他当时就像是——对不起，这把我笑得太厉害了。我不该笑的。但就是那个镜头，如果你们看的话，当安迪和德怀特真正开始干架的时候，比如德怀特走过来，他正在吃三明治。尽管他一直在吃那些热狗，但他还是走了过去，然后他们就开打，埃德就像是在他面前挥舞着手臂。
Somehow in this tussle, Ed broke his fingernail, but he said he broke it really bad. Like it ripped. I think it like ripped below the, um, that's what I, I remember like, it was gruesome looking. It was gruesome. But Ed was like yelling in his sumo shirt. He was yelling, stop, stop. And all he could get out was I broke my nail and people were like, okay, did you break your fingernail?
不知怎么的，在这场扭打中，埃德弄断了指甲，但他说他伤得非常重。就像是撕裂了。我记得它好像裂到了……呃，这就是我记忆中的样子，看起来挺血腥的。太血腥了。但埃德穿着他的相扑服在大喊。他一直在喊：“停下，停下。”他嘴里只能说出：“我指甲断了”，然后大家就问：“好吧，你指甲断了吗？”
And he's like, no guys, I broke my nail. Oh no. Oh no. But he didn't leave set. No, he didn't leave set. They came over and they, but there was that moment when someone was like, what happened? Like Ed broke his nail. And he's like, no, it's more than just a broken nail.
而他却说：“不，伙计们，我的指甲断了。”哦不。哦不。但他没有离开片场。不，他没有离开片场。他们走了过来，而且……但当时有那么一刻，有人问：“怎么回事？”就像是埃德指甲断了。而他说：“不，这可不止是断了个指甲那么简单。”
And then they, they wrapped it up. Well now, Angela, we're going to get into a big moment. This was huge for our show. This is a huge stunt. You have to remember our show never left a little tiny office. So we've got a breakdown. We've got two big things coming up. We've got this Andy floating away and then the coals.
然后他们把伤口包扎好了。好了，安吉拉，我们要进入一个重要时刻了。这对我们的节目来说是个大场面。这是一个巨大的特技。你得记住，我们的节目从来没有离开过那个狭小简陋的办公室。所以我们要分解一下。接下来有两个大场面。我们有安迪漂走，然后是煤炭。
So Jenna, let's start with Andy. Okay. Andy walks over to the water and we had a fan question about this from Ali Joe Higginbotham, who said, when Andy walks to the lake, he has something yellow in his hand. What is he holding and what is he planning to do with it at the shore? Well, he's holding a bandana. He's holding a yellow bandana. Michael had handed these out in the egg race and that's what everyone had used to cover
所以，珍娜，让我们从安迪开始。好的。安迪走向水边，我们有一个关于此事的粉丝提问，来自阿里·乔·希金博瑟姆，她说：“当安迪走向湖边时，他手里拿了块黄色的东西。他拿的是什么？他在岸边打算用它做什么？”好吧，他拿的是一条头巾。他拿着一条黄色的头巾。迈克尔在抢鸡蛋比赛中分发过这些，大家就是用它来蒙住
their eyes. And Andy is holding his yellow bandana from the egg race and he's going to, he hopes to dip it in the water to then maybe wrap it around his neck to cool himself off. This was the idea. Yes. But instead, he falls in the water and starts floating away. When he fell in the water, you know, I wasn't too far off because my character witnesses this.
眼睛的。安迪手里拿着他在抢鸡蛋比赛中分到的黄色头巾，他打算——他希望能把它浸在水里，然后也许可以把它缠在脖子上给自己降温。这就是他的想法。是的。但相反，他掉进水里并开始漂走了。当他掉进水里时，你知道的，我离得不远，因为我的角色目睹了这一切。
Yes. And there's a take that didn't make it, that he literally went, he like rolled, Jenna, he like rolled into the water. But they used this take because it was more clear why he was going down there. He's trying to, trying to hang that bandana in the water. Trying to balance. Well let me say, and we got another frequently asked question from Candace Kelso, Michael Loong, Olive Taylor and Phoebe Bono, was that really Ed in the water or was that a stunt
是的。还有一个没有被采用的镜头，他 literalmente（字面意思）进去了，他就像是滚了进去，珍娜，他就像是滚进了水里。但他们用了现在这个镜头，因为这样更清楚地展现了他为什么要走到那里去。他试图把那条头巾浸在水里。试图保持平衡。好吧，顺便说一句，我们收到了来自坎迪斯·凯尔索、迈克尔·隆、奥利弗·泰勒和菲比·博诺的另一个常见问题：水里那个人真的是埃德吗，还是个特技替身？
double? Guys, that was Ed in the water. Ed did it all. I don't know that they offered him a stunt double. I don't know. Kent told me they offered him a stunt double, but Ed insisted on doing all of the floating in the water himself. He was out there floating for over 45 minutes.
替身？伙计们，在水里的是艾德。艾德包办了一切。我不知道他们是不是给他提供过替身。我不知道。肯跟我说他们提供过替身，但艾德坚持要自己完成水里所有的漂浮动作。他在那儿漂了45分钟以上。
And I'm thinking, maybe when he was like, oh no, I'll fall in the water. Like maybe he didn't realize what that all entailed. Yeah. And perhaps having a stunt double on the side to complete some of the very far away floating. But guys, that is Ed the whole time floating out there. Not only in the day, but then he had to do it again at night. Yeah. This was two different shoots for him in the water, a day scene and a night scene.
我在想，也许当他说，哦不，我会掉进水里。就好像他可能没意识到这需要付出什么。是的。也许旁边有个替身来完成一些远距离的漂浮。但伙计们，全程都是艾德在那儿漂着。不仅是白天，晚上他还得再来一次。是的。他在水里拍了两场不同的戏，一场白天戏和一场夜戏。
Now when he was out there at night, he did have a thin wet suit on underneath all that sumo gear to keep him warm. So they did think of that. But before we get too far into this stunt, Angela, we also had fan questions from Rebecca Gonzalez, Connor N and Maura Anderson, who said, Angela, how did you make it through the scene of Andy floating away? It was so hard. It was, that's what she said.
现在当他晚上在那儿的时候，在所有相扑道具下面，他确实穿了一件薄薄的潜水衣来保暖。所以他们确实考虑到了这一点。但在我们深入探讨这个特技之前，安吉拉，我们还有来自丽贝卡·冈萨雷斯、康纳·N和莫拉·安德森的粉丝提问，他们说，安吉拉，你是怎么熬过安迪漂走的那个场景的？太难了。确实，她就是这么说的。
Oh boy. I'm sorry. It was really, it was really difficult, difficult not to laugh, really difficult, especially because Ed was improvising a little bit. As he floated away, some of that dialogue was not scripted. So you know, when I'm like, I don't really understand what it is you're saying to me. That was scripted. But then Ed, Ed was physically floating away and he was dealing with the elements and he
哦天哪。我很抱歉。真的，真的很难，很难不笑，真的很难，尤其是因为艾德当时有点即兴发挥。当他漂走的时候，有些台词并不是剧本里有的。所以你知道的，当我说，我真的听不懂你在对我说什么。那是剧本里有的。但接着艾德，艾德身体在漂走，他还要应对各种自然因素，他
improvised this line, look at what I'm doing and go tell somebody it. I love that line so much. That was Ed improvising. That is awesome. I know. So it was really hard and I didn't want to laugh because poor Ed is floating out in that water. You know what I mean?
即兴发挥了这句台词：看看我在做什么，去告诉某人。我太喜欢这句台词了。那是艾德即兴发挥的。太棒了。我知道。所以这真的很难，我不想笑，因为可怜的艾德正漂在那片水域里。你知道我的意思吗？
Yes. If you laugh, you ruin that moment and he has to float longer. I was working hard. Oh, the pressure of that. I was working hard not to laugh. Well, we asked Jen about Ed in the water and here's what she had to say. Oh, shooting the Andy floating away scenes was really fun. I love that part of the script.
是的。如果你笑了，你就毁了那个时刻，他就得漂更久。我一直在努力。哦，那压力太大了。我一直在努力不笑。好吧，我们问了珍关于艾德在水里的事，她是这么说的。哦，拍摄安迪漂走的场景真的很有趣。我喜欢剧本里的那部分。
I love when Angela pretends that she doesn't understand what he's saying. That was so much fun to write. I remember that Ed was like in the sumo suit and then there was a rope attached to him and he was being pulled by a boat and then at a certain point the boat would leave him and then he would just drift. But there was also a current. I believe the water was also cold and he had to keep his head up. And I remember that it was a challenging thing because his head would sort of get lost and
我喜欢安吉拉假装听不懂他在说什么。写那一幕太有趣了。我记得艾德穿着相扑服，然后身上系着一根绳子，有一艘船在拉他，然后到了一定程度，船会离开他，接着他就顺流漂着。但当时还有水流。我相信水也很冷，他必须把头抬起来。我记得这是一件很有挑战性的事情，因为他的头会有点沉下去，
it would just like go under unless he helped he put his neck up and just try to hold it up. So I think it was a difficult thing. Also the timing of the boat and the timing was trying to get it on camera with Michael's talking head was difficult. So I remember that Ed was like a real trooper and there were a lot of discussions about like how far out he should be at sea because we wanted to see him. We didn't want to be too obvious that it was him and Michael might see him but we didn't
如果他不努力把脖子抬起来并试着撑住它的话，就会沉到水里。所以我认为这是一件很难的事。还有船的时间配合，以及配合迈克尔的单人访谈把镜头拍好也很难。所以我记得艾德就像一个真正的勇士，大家讨论了很多关于他在海上应该离多远的问题，因为我们想看到他。我们不想太明显地看出那是他，迈克尔可能会看到他，但我们又不想
want him to be so far away that he was this tiny little dot. So Ed was in the water for quite a while while we tried to work this out. And the other thing I remember which is crazy to say now but there was a safety meeting right before it and I feel like the very beginning of the safety meeting like Ed was there but like he was just getting there because everything was so rushed and I think the safety person said one thing like as Ed was approaching that I wasn't sure Ed clocked and I had this moment of should I tell him or not and I remember the safety guy talking about water snakes and I was like oh my god oh my god do I repeat this Ed do I not repeat this Ed I don't think
他离得太远，以至于成了一个小黑点。所以我们在努力解决这个问题时，艾德在水里待了相当长的一段时间。我记得的另一件事，现在说起来挺疯狂的，就是在拍摄前开过一个安全会议，我觉得在安全会议刚开始的时候，艾德也在，但他当时刚到，因为一切都太匆忙了，我觉得安全人员在艾德走近时说了一句话，我不太确定艾德有没有听进去，我当时有一种纠结的时刻，我是该告诉他还是不该告诉他，我记得安全人员提到过水蛇，我当时想，哦天哪，哦天哪，我要把这个重复给艾德听吗，我要不要对艾德重复这个，我觉得
I repeated it to Ed because like he was going to be in this water it was going to be very cold I thought would I want to know about water snakes before I got into the water in a sumo suit or not so yeah I think I made that decision tell me if you think that was the correct decision to make anyway so there were a lot of challenges of shooting that there were no snake events during the shooting of that sequence and I thought Ed did a phenomenal job and so did Angela and I'm just in love with that sequence of events but it was challenging to shoot wow Ed Ed possibility of water snakes oh my god oh boy Jen Salada well now Jen mentioned in her clip that they would have to pull Ed behind a boat to get him in place so Kent
我没有把这个告诉艾德，因为他马上就要下水了，水会非常冷，我想换作是我，在穿着相扑服下水之前，我会想知道关于水蛇的事吗？所以，是的，我想我做了那个决定，你们告诉我你们觉得这个决定做对没有。不管怎样，拍摄那场戏有很多挑战，在拍摄那段戏的过程中没有发生水蛇事件，我觉得艾德表现得极其出色，安吉拉也是，我太喜欢那一连串的事件了，但拍摄起来确实很有挑战性，哇，艾德，艾德遇到水蛇的可能性，哦天哪，哦天哪，珍·萨拉达，现在珍在她的片段中提到，他们必须用船拉着艾德才能把他弄到指定位置，所以肯
told me that power boats were not allowed on the lake so they had to have a stunt coordinator in a row boat I remember Jenna I remember rowing him yeah can you imagine if you're somewhere else at this park and you're just hiking or maybe you're riding a horse from the equestrian center and you look out onto the lake and you see a man in a row boat rowing another man by a rope who's in a sumo suit what are you thinking when you see that I don't know I don't know are you worried what are you thinking so I watched this play out because we would have to reset Ed to that spot where we would have dialogue and inevitably he'd float away right and then they would the guy there he was he and I had to make sure I didn't
告诉我，湖里不允许开机动船，所以他们必须让一个特技协调员坐在划艇里。我记得，珍娜，我记得划船送他，是的。想象一下，如果你在这个公园的其他地方，你只是在远足，或者也许你正从马术中心骑着马，然后你望向湖面，看到一个人坐在划艇里，用绳子拉着另一个穿着相扑服的人，当你看到那个时你在想什么？我不知道，我不知道，你在担心什么？你在想什么？所以我看着这一幕上演，因为我们得把艾德重新弄回那个有台词的位置，然后不可避免地他会漂走，对吧，然后他们，那里的那个人，他和我都必须确保我没有
look at the row boat guy right you know like I couldn't have my art my eyes dart away but off that in the periphery of my vision was this guy in a boat and he would row and pull Ed Ed had a harness suit on under the sumo suit and they put through the arm of this the sumo suit a fishing line yeah and this guy would pull Ed and as he did Jenna I would see water break around his body you know like something in the water yeah and Ed said that a majority of that water as he was being pulled would flush through the suit oh my god and out his neck well can't told me if you look carefully in the Michael talking head where Ed is floating in the background you will see that there's a pretty strong current in
看着划艇的那个人，你知道吧，我的视线不能移开，但在我余光中，那个人就在船上，他会划船并拉着艾德，艾德在相扑服里面穿着一套安全背心，他们在相扑服的袖子那里穿了一根钓鱼线，是的，这个人会拉着艾德，当他这么做的时候，珍娜，我会看到水在他身体周围裂开，你知道的，就像水里有什么东西一样，是的，艾德说当他被拉着时，绝大部分的水都会灌进衣服里，哦天哪，然后从他的脖子流出来。好吧，肯告诉我，如果你仔细看迈克尔的单人访谈画面，也就是艾德在背景里漂着的那一段，你会发现水流相当急，
the water but Ed is not moving that is because at that point the only way to keep him in the shot was to just keep him attached to the boat and so he said if you look for it he's very oddly staying in one place while a pretty heavy current is going underneath him so so insane Angela I also got the story about these sumo suits from Carrie Bennett our wardrobe designer oh let's hear it so she said that this was one of the most difficult costume challenges she had for our show she had to create these inflatable sumo suits but because she knew Andy would end up floating away in it whatever she put them in had to be safe for him to float on water so she said as soon as she read the script she immediately
但艾德却没有动。那是因为在那一点上，唯一能让他留在镜头里的方法就是把他一直拴在船上，所以他说如果你仔细看，他非常奇怪地停在同一个地方，而一股相当猛烈的水流正在他身下流过。所以太疯狂了。安吉拉，我还从我们的服装设计师嘉莉·班尼特那里听到了这些相扑服的故事。哦，让我们听听。所以她说这是她为我们的节目遇到的最具挑战性的服装设计之一，她必须制作这些充气相扑服，但因为她知道安迪最后会穿着它漂走，无论她把他们穿成什么样，都必须保证他在水上漂浮时是安全的，所以她说一读完剧本，她就立刻
went to Greg and said I cannot design a costume that will allow someone to float on water I need a stunt person to help me so she got together with the stunt person and they realized that kind of like what Jen said the biggest challenge was keeping his head from going underwater because she was like his body would float but the head would go under so that is why the guys are wearing those crazy head pieces in the episode those were custom made right yes yeah she said what if I made a floaty helmet in the shape of like a sumo wrestlers bun and the bun is actually a floating device brilliant so she designed this extra bit of safety for Ed with this floaty bun and before we shot they went over to Kent's a bornex
去找格雷格说，我设计不出一件能让人在水上漂浮的服装，我需要一个特技人员来帮我。于是她和特技人员聚在一起，他们意识到就像珍说的那样，最大的挑战是防止他的头沉入水下，因为她说他的身体会浮起来，但头会沉下去，这就是为什么这集里的人们戴着那些疯狂的头饰，那些是定制的对吧？是的，是的，她说如果我做一个形状像相扑选手发髻的浮力头盔会怎么样，那个发髻实际上是一个漂浮装置。太天才了。所以她为艾德设计了带有这个浮力发髻的额外安全装置，在拍摄之前，他们去了肯位于博纳克斯的
pool and they put a stunt guy in the suit and they tested it out and it worked oh my gosh you're talking about what happens when like someone's riding a horse by and Ed's floating and there's a guy with a rowboat what about Kent's family hey dad what's who's in the pool don't worry about it it's a little thing for work totally totally also when these guys in the writers room wrote this sequence they had no idea the paces that they would put people through to make it realized on screen it was just a funny idea oh you know what would be funny they wrestle in these sumo suits and then Ed falls in the water and floats away I mean the amount of effort that went into making that happen I know I
泳池，把一个特技演员塞进服装里进行了测试，结果管用了。哦天哪，你刚刚说到有人骑马经过而艾德在漂浮，还有个人划着划艇，那肯的家人呢？嘿，爸爸，泳池里的是谁？别管那个了，那是工作的一小部分。完全正确，完全正确。另外，当编剧室里的这群人写下这个桥段时，他们完全不知道为了在银幕上实现它，他们会把大家折腾成什么样，这只是个有趣的点子。哦，你知道什么会很有趣吗？他们在相扑相扑服里摔跤，然后艾德掉进水里漂走了。我是说，为了实现这一点所付出的努力。我知道，
think about this all the time with our scripts like oh it'll be funny we'll have a funeral for a bird but we need a specialized tiny coffin made yeah and several dead birds to choose from mm-hmm and then Jim and Karen sneak off and they're sneaking off to call David but Pam doesn't know that but you know she saw them walk away you know she did she's aware yeah and they have this moment where they you know call David Jim says he wants to be considered and then Karen does and then Jim is like teasing her because she she sort of fumbles her words right when she calls David yeah I didn't think that was cool boyfriend behavior I have to say oh right because she's she's trying to leave a professional message
我总是联想到我们的剧本，哦，这会很有趣，我们要为一只鸟办一场葬礼，但我们需要定制一个精致的小棺材，还要准备几只死鸟供挑选。然后吉姆和凯伦溜走了，他们溜出去给大卫打电话，但帕姆不知道，不过你知道的，她看到他们走开了，你知道她看到了，她注意到了。然后他们有了一个打电话给大卫的时刻，吉姆说他想被考虑，然后凯伦也这么说了，接着吉姆开始取笑她，因为她在给大卫打电话时有点语无伦次，对吧？是的，我觉得这不是一个好男友的行为，我必须这么说。哦，对吧，因为她试图留言保持专业，
right she's speaking to David Wallace and she's saying she'd like to be considered for this job and he's kind of heckling her during this phone call and I and he's distracting her and I know I think it was meant to be kind of like cute and playful but I don't know if I'm if I'm making a professional phone call I don't appreciate being heckled don't mess with me don't mess with me when I'm making an important boss lady call or is he trying to sabotage he might be trying to sandwich this moment he tried to sandwich it well we also mentioned earlier that this was an added scene originally these phone calls happened in the office before we went to beach day but they made a change and they decided it was
对吧，她正在跟大卫·瓦伦斯讲话，并说她想被考虑争取这份工作，而他在这个电话过程中一直在取笑她，他在分散她的注意力。我知道，这本来可能是想表现得可爱和顽皮，但我不确定，如果我是在打一个工作电话，我不喜欢被人取笑。别烦我，当我正在打一个重要的老板女士电话时别烦我。还是说他是在试图搞破坏？他可能是在试图搅黄这一刻，他试图搅黄它。好吧，我们之前也提到过，这是一个后来加的场景，最初这些电话是在去海滩日之前的办公室里打的，但他们做了改动，并决定最好晚点再透露这个信息，
better to reveal this information later but this led to problems like we already had such a packed day and here we were trying to add little moments and add little scenes and Jen actually talked about this as one of the challenges just trying to get everything shot on these days because you know you have so many things you have to shoot in daylight and then the sun goes down you can't make it stay out also these were such big ambitious days and if we would go past the allotted time we would get into overtime which was incredibly expensive for the show because they would have to pay the crew overtime the actors overtime and so Kent Sabornak our line producer was trying to keep us on our day and he was having to
但这导致了一些问题，比如我们本来就已经有满满一整天的工作了，而现在我们还试图加入一些小片段和加塞小场景。珍实际上把这当作挑战之一谈论过，就是试图在这些天里把所有东西都拍完，因为你知道的，你有那么多东西必须在白天拍完，然后太阳下山了，你可没办法让太阳不落山。此外，这些都是规模宏大、雄心勃勃的拍摄日，如果我们超过了规定的时间，我们就会进入加班时间，这对剧组来说成本极其高昂，因为他们必须支付工作人员加班费、演员加班费，所以我们的制片主任肯·萨博纳克一直在努力让我们按时完成当天的拍摄，并且他不得不
check in with Jen and Harold quite a bit about it yeah here's what she had to say about that and I remember Kent being very patient with us and giving us extra time and adding in cushions but it was still really difficult to get everything that we needed to get done I mean we were going very fast and working incredibly efficiently it was just hard and I remember there was one moment where Kent had already given us a cushion and maybe even a second cushion and then we were about to go over it but we were almost done we were so close to being done but Kent called and I got the call and we were about ready to say you know Harold was about ready to call action and Kent is like frustrated because
跟珍和哈罗德就此进行相当多的沟通。是的，以下是她对此的看法。我记得肯对我们非常有耐心，给我们留了额外的时间，还增加了缓冲时间，但要完成我们需要做的一切依然非常困难。我的意思是，我们当时进展极快，工作效率高得难以置信，只是确实很难。我记得有一次，肯已经给了我们一段缓冲时间，甚至可能是第二段缓冲时间，然后我们就要超时了，但我们快拍完了，我们离拍完就差那么一点点了，但肯打了电话进来，我接了电话，我们正准备说，哈罗德正准备喊开始，而肯却很沮丧，因为
he wants us to be done because he's given us extra time and he wants us to be done and completely understandable but I knew that if I kept talking to Kent we were gonna be slowed down by 10 seconds at that point and that 10 seconds would allow us to finish the shot so Kent is talking to me and a very gently and gingerly just put the phone down on a chair and we got the last shot and we were done it was definitely this weird moment of like this is the producer of your show telling you that you need to stop shooting and I realized I can either talk to him about the fact that we're gonna stop shooting or get the shot so we got the shot it was definitely one of those moments of like I hope that was cool
他希望我们完成了，因为他已经给了我们额外的时间，他希望我们拍完收工，这完全可以理解，但我知道如果我继续跟肯说话，那个时候我们就会被耽误10秒钟，而那10秒钟本可以让我们拍完那个镜头。所以肯在跟我说话，我非常轻柔小心地把电话放在一张椅子上，然后我们拍完了最后一个镜头，收工了。这绝对是一个很奇妙的时刻，就像这是你的剧组制片人在告诉你需要停止拍摄，而我意识到，要么我可以跟他谈谈我们将要停止拍摄的事，要么就去把镜头拍下来。所以我们拍下了那个镜头，这绝对是那种会让人觉得希望这举动没问题吧的时刻。
Angela I think that what Jen is talking about is a little bit of sabotage is she sabotaging is she she's not sabotaging she's sabotaging her phone call right so that they could get these shots I think it's pretty amazing like I can sort of just visualize Kent going on and on like Jen you can't keep adding scenes and she just set the phone down and was like yes do it one more time one more time while he's venting yes exactly well you guys part of Kent's job he has such a hard job because he answers to both Greg who is the creative voice of the show and you know his job is to make all of Greg's dreams come true creatively but he also answers to the network who has given him a budget and a timetable and you
安吉拉，我觉得珍所说的那是在搞点小破坏。她是去搞破坏吗？她不是在搞破坏，她是在破坏她的电话通话，好让他们能拍完这些镜头。我觉得这挺了不起的，我简直能想象出肯没完没了地说，珍，你不能一直加戏，而她只是把电话放下，说，是的，再来一次，再来一次，而他还在发泄。是的，完全如此。好吧，伙计们，这是肯工作的一部分，他的工作太难了，因为他既要对格雷格负责，格雷格是节目的创意之音，你知道他的工作是让格雷格所有的创意梦想成真，但他同时也要向电视网负责，电视网给了他预算和时间表，你
can't spend more money than this and everything that you said earlier Angela about staying on time because Kent will look at a script and he will try to estimate based on conversations with the director and the writer and the crew how long each scene will take so he'll say all right we need three hours to film Ed at sea but we I'm only going to give 45 minutes to Jim and Karen in the sand that's right and if any of these things go over even 10 minutes they have to steal 10 minutes from another scene and it is becomes just this logistical nightmare and Kent has to keep an eye on all of it and it is a vicious domino effect to once you get off it just spirals your whole day I feel like this is like a
不能花超过这个数目的钱，还有你刚才说的所有关于按时完成的话题，因为肯会看剧本，他会根据与导演、编剧和剧组的沟通，试图估算每个场景需要花多长时间。所以他会说，好了，我们需要三个小时来拍摄艾德在海上的戏，但吉姆和凯伦在沙滩上的戏我只能给45分钟。没错，如果这里面有任何一个环节超时哪怕10分钟，他们就得从另一个场景里偷出10分钟，这简直变成了一场后勤噩梦，肯必须密切关注这一切，一旦进度脱轨，就会产生恶性多米诺骨牌效应，让你的整天都陷入螺旋式失控。我觉得这就像是
great metaphor for partnerships because I feel like in every family there's one person that's a little bit of the big thinker dreamer on vacation we'll do all of this and then there's the person in the relationship that's like I've allotted $80 for things at the gift shop that's all we're spending at the gift shop okay because if we spend more than $80 at the gift shop we can't do that extra bungee cord thing that you all want to do yes that is exactly Kent yes that person keep us on budget keep us on time yep well now Angela it is time for the coal walk talk about a big scene this was a big evening for us it was a very ambitious shoot we had a lot to cover we had we could not start till it got
伙伴关系的一个伟大隐喻，因为我觉得在每个家庭里，总有一个人有点像是空想家、梦想家，去度假时会计划做所有这些事，然后关系里还有另一个人会说，我在礼品店的东西上只分配了80美元的预算，我们在礼品店只能花这么多，好吧，因为如果我们在这个礼品店花了超过80美元，我们就没法做你们大家都想玩的那个蹦极项目了。是的，那绝对就是肯。那种人能让我们保持在预算内，按时完成。是的。好了，现在，安吉拉，是时候聊聊走炭火戏了。说起一场重头戏，对我们来说这是一个重大的夜晚。这是一场雄心勃勃的拍摄，我们需要拍很多内容，天黑前我们根本没法开工。
dark yep and there was a lot of prep I don't know if you remember Jenna how they made those coals do you remember I do it was multi-layered and we had a lot of people ask this question about how did you make the coals we got mail from Ellie Troutman Chandra M Jamie S Heather Donnelly Renee are and many others they wanted to know how did the props department create the hot coals they looked so real because guys these were not real coals yes so we could not have a huge fire here you guys we were allowed to have the tiki torches and little small flames for example when the when the pile of wood burst into flames that's all special effects that was not at all a fire they put that in in post because there were
是的，而且有很多筹备工作。我不知道你是否还记得，珍娜，他们是怎么制作那些炭火的，你记得吗？我记得。它是多层的，有很多人问过这个问题，你们是怎么制作炭火的？我们收到了来自埃利·特劳特曼、钱德拉·M、杰米·S、希瑟·唐纳利、蕾妮·R和许多其他人的信，他们想知道道具部门是如何创造出炽热的炭火的。它们看起来太真实了，因为伙计们，这些根本不是真的炭火。是的，所以我们这里不能生起巨大的一堆火，伙计们，我们被允许使用火把和一些微小的火焰，例如当成堆的木头突然燃起大火焰时，那全都是特效，根本不是真正的火。那是后期加上去的，因为
fire regulations at this particular park right so well there are fire regulations in California in general yes yes absolutely so Harold Ramis talked a little bit about this coal fire pit on the DVD commentary he said they started first of all by digging a big hole in the ground and then they buried in the ground a light box just a big box that lit up and then they put on top of the light box these little yellow and orange gels to make it look like a flame and then on top of those light gels on top of the light box they put little lava rocks and then running on either side of this hole in the ground they had put two gas lines with very small little flickers of real fire that popped out of the ground
这个特定的公园有消防法规，对吧？嗯，加州总的来说是有消防法规的。是的，是的，绝对是。所以哈罗德·拉米斯在DVD评论音轨中谈到了一些关于这个炭火坑的事情。他说他们首先在地上挖了一个大洞，然后在地下埋了一个灯箱，就是一个会发光的方大箱子，接着他们在灯箱顶部放了这些小黄、橙色滤光片来让它看起来像火焰，然后在灯箱顶部的这些滤光片上面，他们放了小块的火山岩，然后沿着这个地下洞穴的两侧，他们铺设了两条燃气管道，里面有从小洞里冒出来的非常小簇的真实火焰。
yes and because there was real fire as part of the coal walk we had a very big safety meeting about that one of our biggest yeah for sure it's particularly important because as you know rain as Dwight is going to walk on to these hot coals stand there and then follow the ground and that was real fire next to him on either side of him yes and I remember when rain did that one of the most painful things for rain was being barefoot on the lava rocks it hurt it's like it's like stepping on a Lego you know how that feels I do know how it feels because I did it as well yeah in fact I'll say that people have mentioned that I look like my feet really hurt after I walk across the hot coals and they've wondered
是的，因为走炭火戏中包含了真实的火，我们为此开了一场非常大型的安全会议，是我们开过最大的一场之一，肯定的。这尤其重要，因为如你所知，雷恩饰演的德怀特要走上这些炽热的炭火，站在那儿然后摔倒在地上，而在他身旁的两侧就是真正的火。是的，我记得当雷恩那样做时，对雷恩来说最痛苦的事情之一就是赤脚踩在火山岩上。很痛，就像，就像踩在乐高积木上一样，你知道那种感觉吗？我确实知道那种感觉，因为我也经历过。是的，事实上，我要说的是，有人提到过在我走过热炭之后，我的脚看起来真的很痛，他们想知道
if I really walked on hot coals no my feet were sore and bruised from having to run across lava rocks over and over again yeah like my feet did kind of hurt throw a bunch of like hard Legos on the ground and run back and forth over them that's as good as a coal walk right there a Lego walk if you want that experience you can do it at home Michael wanted everyone to walk over the hot coals we said he has to go first in Steve's hesitation as Michael to go over those coals Jenna was so brilliant his whole body posture the expression on his face and he improvised the line the mine has to wrap around the foot that was an improvisation I did not look that up I love knowing that and we have a call back to this whole runner
我是不是真的走在了热炭上。没有，我的脚因为不得不一遍又一遍地跑过火山岩而又痛又青。是的，就像我的脚确实挺痛的。在地上扔一把硬质乐高积木，然后在它们上面来回跑，那就跟走炭火差不多了，如果你想要那种体验，你在家里就能做到。迈克尔希望每个人都走过热炭，我们说他必须第一个上。史蒂夫作为迈克尔在走过那些炭火前的犹豫，珍娜，真是太精彩了，他的整个身体姿态，他脸上的表情，而且他即兴发挥了那句台词，心灵必须包裹双脚，那是一个即兴发挥。我没有查过剧本，我很高兴知道这一点。我们呼应了前面贯穿始终的一个桥段，
of Angela being grossed out by Kevin's feet yes she's like I am not going to go after you and your gross feet and he's like Angela is like a thousand degrees one of my favorite moments in this whole sequence is when Michael says to the group he's so disappointed that no one has walked across the coals except sort of Dwight and he says you know what it's clear to me that if I had to name my replacement today it would be Mr. Outside Hire and then Angela says or Mrs. Outside Hire and Michael is like yes or that I know but a little bit of Angela sauce there like I pointed my finger yeah wait Jenna we we do have a background catch we can't pass up it's too good say it while Michael's going on and on about who
也就是安吉拉对凯芬的脚感到恶心。是的，她说，我才不要跟在你这双恶心的脚后面呢，而他说，安吉拉，这有上千度呢。整段戏中最让我喜欢的时刻之一，就是迈克尔对大家说，他感到非常失望，因为除了德怀特勉强算之外，居然没有人走过炭火，然后他说，你知道吗，很显然，如果我今天必须指认我的接替者，那将会是外聘先生。接着安吉拉说，或者外聘女士。然后迈克尔说，是的，或者那个。我知道，但这里带有一点安吉拉式的风格，我竖起了手指。是的，等等，珍娜，我们有一个背景穿帮，我们不能错过，太棒了。说出来听听。就在迈克尔滔滔不绝地说着谁
won't walk across the coals and he's like an Andy is never here today it pans past us to the water Andy has floated into the marsh he's stuck yeah on his back poor Ed in the dark in the lake and at 19 minutes 55 seconds you can see his wetsuit on his arm oh yeah on his arm his arm is like extended out of his sumo suit and you can see the beige wetsuit that he had to put on because it was so cold and then people wrote in Angela and they said how come in season nine when Pam is crying the documentary crew helps her but when Andy is floating away at night they just turn off the camera lights and walk away I know I know that's one of the questions Jack had my stepson he was like why did why the camera crew not
不肯走过炭火，然后他说连安迪今天都不在的时候，镜头掠过我们转向水面，安迪已经漂到了沼泽里，他卡住了。是的，仰面躺着。可怜的艾德，在黑暗中的湖里。在19分55秒时，你可以看到他胳膊上穿着潜水衣。哦，对，在他的胳膊上。他的胳膊从相扑服里伸出来，你可以看到他不得不穿上的米色潜水衣，因为水实在太冷了。然后人们写信给安吉拉说，怎么在第九季里，当帕姆哭泣时，纪录片摄制组会帮助她，而当安迪在夜里漂走时，他们只是关掉摄影机灯然后走开了？我知道，我知道，这是我继子杰克提出的问题之一，他当时问，为什么摄制组不
help him you know at that moment they were like we can't disturb yeah the natural course of the story right must just document it well we're coming up to this big moment there is a huge moment about to happen for Pam yeah she wants to run across the coals and Michael says no no yeah and then he moves them on and he wants them all to speak Dwight is doing his version of the aristocrats very badly and in the background Pam runs across the coals yeah and this just feeds her soul she feels so alive in this moment she did this one thing for herself and she runs over to the group and she wants to share yeah and she gives this speech and everything just comes pouring out her disappointment that
去帮他呢？你知道的，在那个时刻，他们觉得，我们不能打扰故事的自然发展，对吧？必须如实记录下来。好吧，我们马上要迎来这个重大的时刻了。帕姆即将迎来一个重大的时刻。是的，她想跑过炭火，而迈克尔说，不，不。是的，然后他让他们继续前进，他想让每个人都发言。德怀特正在非常糟糕地表演他的《贵族》版本，而在背景里，帕姆跑过了炭火。是的，这滋养了她的心灵，在这一刻她觉得自己充满了活力。她为自己做了这唯一的一件事，然后她跑回人群，她想要分享。
people didn't come to the art show but more than that her feelings for Jim and how much she misses him and the truth the big truth which is that while there were many reasons to call off her wedding to Roy the reason she did it was because of how she feels about Jim yeah and oof first of all I sat next to John in the scene Angela and Jim are side by side I don't know if you noticed that I did and so when you were talking to Jim I was right in your eye line you know I couldn't believe my luck honestly because this is such a beautiful performance by you Jenna you do such a great job it's so moving to watch you as Pam transition through all of those beats and I had this out of body experience
接着她发表了这段演讲，所有的情绪倾泻而出，她对大家没有来看她的艺术展感到失望，但更深的是她对吉姆的感情以及她有多么想念他，还有那个真相，那个重大的真相，那就是，虽然当初取消她和罗伊的婚礼有很多原因，但她这样做的真正原因是因为她对吉姆的感情。是的。哦！首先，我在那个场景里挨着约翰坐，安吉拉，吉姆和我就并排坐着。我不知道你有没有注意到这一点。我注意到了。所以当你在跟吉姆说话时，我就在你的视线正前方。你知道吗，老实说，我简直不敢相信自己的运气，因为这是你非常精彩的一段表演，珍娜，你演得太棒了，看着你饰演的帕姆经历所有这些情绪转折，真的非常感人。而我当时有一种灵魂出窍的感觉，
as your friend watching you in awe give this fantastic performance wanting to tear up and cry because my friend was crushing it and then having to be Angela Martin who would never react to you that way and then at the same time just being in awe of this moment it was it was just a beautiful thing to watch Jenna you did such a great job and you had to do it over and over we did several takes because they had to get people's reactions and every time you crushed it every single time well a lot of people ask if that speech was improvised or partially improvised and it was not that was all written and as Jen shared with us written by Greg Daniels and I memorized it and delivered it word for word
作为你的朋友，看着你惊叹于你贡献了如此精彩的表演，我很想落泪哭泣，因为我的朋友简直演炸了，然而同时我还要扮演安吉拉·马丁，她绝不会对你有那种反应。但在那一刻，只是对这一幕感到惊叹，看着真的很美好。珍娜，你演得太棒了，而且你不得不一遍又一遍地拍。我们拍了好几条，因为他们必须捕捉大家的反应，而你每一次都演炸裂了，每一次都是。好吧，很多人问那段演讲是即兴的还是部分即兴的，其实并不是，全都是写好的。正如珍跟我们分享的那样，那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯写的，我把它背了下来，一个字不差地演绎出来。
I worked on it for a very long time and I remember I remember trying to think about those times in my life where you've done something that give you a burst of adrenaline and that's what I wanted her to come into the speech with she's just done this call walk and she has this burst of adrenaline and she doesn't even think about that she's going to share it's it's completely different this is very impulsive and that was that was kind of what I put behind the speech but I knew that speech backwards and forwards I could have delivered it for days because I also know as an actor at least for me especially the more I know the material the less I have to think of the word exactly and it can just be about the
我为之准备了很长时间，我记得我试着去回想生活中那些让你肾上腺素飙升的时刻，这就是我希望她带着这种状态进入演讲的原因。她刚刚完成了走炭火，体内的肾上腺素飙升，她甚至没有去想要不要分享，这是完全不同的，这是极其冲动的，这就是我赋予这段演讲背后的情绪。但我对这段演讲倒背如流，我可以连续几天把它讲出来，因为作为一个演员我也知道，至少对我来说，尤其是当我对手头的材料了解得越透彻，我就越不需要去琢磨具体的字眼，
performance I was I never had to search for it I had it it was like yeah a little tape in my head that's exactly right you don't have to worry about what you're saying and you can just really experience the moment and feel it because the words are all there and I just thought it was brilliant and I thought everyone's reactions were great because there's there's um there is a dance that you do on a show like the office there is the person who is driving the scene who's putting out all this information and then the other side of the story is the people reacting to it and the two parts are very important and I thought that John is Jim his reactions were great everyone in the crowd they cut to Rashida
从而可以完全专注于表演。我从来不需要去搜寻台词，我已经掌握了它，就像我脑海里有一条小磁带一样。完全正确，你不需要担心自己在说什么，你可以真正地去体验那个时刻并去感受它，因为台词全都在那儿了。我只是觉得这太天才了，而且我觉得每个人的反应都很棒，因为，呃，在《办公室》这样的节目里，有一种舞蹈般的互动。有那种推动场景发展、抛出所有信息的人，而故事的另一面则是做出反应的人，这两部分都非常重要。我觉得约翰饰演的吉姆，他的反应太棒了，人群里的每个人，镜头切到拉什达时，
oh my god her look is Karen was amazing it was like I can't believe this is happening oh my god it was everything and also heartbreak it was all of it yeah well and you mention about what it's like to be the person driving a scene this was kind of my first experience with that and it was this huge speech and that's another reason why I made sure I knew every single word and I got a real glimpse at what Steve does every single day every single week wow delivering these big speeches to the group I mean all your eyeballs were on me I was so nervous yeah it's a lot of work it's a lot of work and not just the cast watching you the whole crew it's everything yeah well I thought it was so great I just
天哪，凯伦当时的表情太惊艳了，就好像，我不敢相信正在发生这一切，天哪，一切尽在不言中。还有心碎，包含了所有的情绪。是的，好吧，而且你提到作为推动场景发展的人是什么感觉，这可以说是我的初次体验，这是一段非常长的演讲，这也是为什么我确保自己知道每一个字，而且我真正瞥见了史蒂夫每天、每周都在做的事情。哇，对大家发表这些长篇大论。我的意思是，所有的目光都聚焦在我身上，我太紧张了。是的，这工作量太大了，这工作量太大了。不仅是演员在看着你，还有整个剧组，一切都在看着你。是的，好吧，我觉得太棒了，我真的
loved it so much well thank you you know I hadn't seen it since at first aired and when I watched it I was really proud of myself you should like oh my gosh I love that that performance is on tape and I can watch it later because it really made me feel like a good actress I was like oh look at me go you are a good actress you should feel that way you should well I was always I was always curious why they sat me next to Jim and didn't have Karen next to him and then that moment ends with Jim looking straight ahead and me kind of looking off to the side like oh my god yeah I think you are there to be the audience reflected right you're what everyone at home is like whoa so I think it was good
太喜欢了。好吧，谢谢你。你知道的，自从它首播以来我就没再看过，当我再次观看时，我真的为自己感到骄傲。你理应如此。哦天哪，我太喜欢那段表演被录在磁带上，我以后还能看，因为它真的让我觉得自己是个好演员。我当时想，哦，看看我多棒。你就是个好演员，你就该有这种感觉，应该的。好吧，我一直，我一直很好奇为什么他们让我坐在吉姆旁边，而不让凯伦坐在他旁边，然后那个场景以吉姆目视前方结束，而我则有点把头转向一边，就好像，天哪。是的，我觉得你在那里是为了成为观众的倒影，对吧？你是所有在家里看节目的观众，觉得，哇。所以我觉得有你在那里，作为对话的另一部分，挺好的。
to have you there being that other piece of the conversation yeah but you know the episode was supposed to end there in the script that's the end of the episode but we added a little tag back on the bus singing on the bus and this tag confused a lot of people well it's daytime we're clearly happy none of this has happened it doesn't make any time sequential sense right yes everyone wanted to know did you sleep at the beach you're all in the same clothes how does everyone look like they've bathed if they spent the night at the beach they just threw this tag on the end it was an extra little bit of fun from the episode it was not meant to be sequential yeah we did not spend the night at the beach story wise
但你知道的，剧本里这集本来应该在那儿结束的，那是这集的结尾。但我们在结尾加了一个小尾巴，大家在公车上唱歌。而这个尾巴让很多人感到困惑。好吧，那是白天，我们显然很开心，这跟之前的任何事情在时间上都连不上，毫无时间连续性，对吧？是的，每个人都想问，你们是在海滩上过夜了吗？你们都穿着同样的衣服，如果你们在海滩上过夜了，怎么每个人看起来都洗过澡一样？他们只是把这个尾巴贴在了结尾，这是这集里多出来的一点乐趣，并不是按时间顺序连贯的。是的，从剧情上来说我们并没有在海滩上过夜。
yeah they just in editing they liked it they like to end on this sort of upbeat you know there's this huge emotional moment has just happened and then it's us all as a group and Ed said in the DVD commentary that he started the song the Flintstones on the bus and for him it was a nod to planes trains and automobiles mmm which I love I love that too you know they do something similar in the Valentine's Day episode they had that little bit of extra footage of Steve improvising in front of the theater and they threw that bit on the end as a tag for Valentine's Day so it's just something we did sometimes yeah and I think you can get away with that in a cold open in a tag they sort of can be their little
是的，他们只是在剪辑时觉得这样挺好，他们喜欢以这种欢快的方式结束，你知道的，刚刚发生了这么巨大的情感高潮，然后是我们大家作为集体在一起。艾德在DVD评论音轨中说过，他在公车上起头唱了《摩登原始人》，对他来说，这是对电影《飞机、火车和汽车》的致敬，嗯，我很喜欢。我也很喜欢这个。你知道的，他们在情人节那一集里也做过类似的事情，他们在剧院前面加入了史蒂夫即兴表演的一小段额外素材，然后把那段作为情人节那集的尾巴贴在结尾，所以这只是我们有时会做的事情。是的，而且我觉得你可以在冷开场或尾巴里这么做，它们可以算是独立的时刻。
standalone moments but Jenna before we wrap this up I wrote about some of my memories of filming this episode in my journal and I said one of the things I loved is that Rashida and I had our trailers side by side in the parking lot mm-hmm and we weren't very far away we were just really close to the catering truck and so in the morning Harold Ramis would get his coffee and Jen and they would have to walk past Rashida and I and we would sit on like the front steps of my trailer like it was our front stoop right yeah and we would visit in the mornings with Harold and Jen and I have a photo of us and you know having our coffee in the morning I just love it I love that I love that I love that memory
但珍娜，在我们结束之前，我在日记里写下了一些我拍摄这集时的回忆，我说我喜欢的一点是，拉什达和我的化妆车在停车场是并排的，嗯，我们离得不远，离餐饮车非常近。所以在早上，哈罗德·拉米斯会去拿他的咖啡，还有珍，他们不得不从我和拉什达身边走过，而我们俩会坐在我的化妆车前台阶上，就像坐在我们自己的前廊台阶一样，对吧？是的，我们会在早晨和哈罗德、珍叙旧。我有一张我们一起喝早咖啡的照片，我太喜欢了，我太喜欢那个回忆了。
so much I don't know if we can say enough what an honor and pleasure it was to work with him but Jen also mentioned this in one of her audio clips yeah what it meant to her to have the opportunity to work with him I'm so glad he was the person in charge of this crazy crazy episode yes because he was such a delight Jenna I remembered as I was going through photos do you remember because him and Jen had to be kind of far away where we were filming that he had a microphone and he would give sort of big general notes on this microphone and then we would yell at him to tell us jokes and he would tell us jokes and in the DVD rain they said that rain would say tell us more about Groundhog Day
真的太喜欢了。不知道我们是否能充分表达能与他合作是多么荣幸和愉快的事，但珍也在她的一个音频片段中提到了这一点，是的，有机会与他合作对她意味着什么。我太高兴他是这个疯狂透顶的节目的负责人了，是的，因为他太令人愉快了。珍娜，我记得当我翻看照片时，你还记得吗？因为他和珍必须离我们拍摄的地方有点远，所以他有一个麦克风，他会通过这个麦克风给出一些总体的大方向意见，然后我们会朝他大喊让他给我们讲笑话，他就会给我们讲笑话，在DVD里，雷恩说雷恩会喊，给我们多讲讲《土拨鼠之日》的故事吧。
he would he would share little bits of trivia on this microphone to us you know as we were way far away on the beach and he just made it all so fun well Jen mentioned that he was really instrumental in mentoring her and actually Sam why don't you play that clip one moment another thing that happened on that episode was there was a there was a it was a challenging episode because we had a lot to get and and the elements were tricky to I remember it was like incredibly cold and there were heat lamps and it was also scorching hot sometimes and within the course of one day so there were a lot of additional challenges that episode and there was one day where it was like we were not gonna make
他会通过那个麦克风跟我们分享一些小八卦，你知道的，当时我们离得那么远，在海滩上，他把这一切变得非常有趣。好吧，珍提到他在指导她方面发挥了真正关键的作用，事实上，萨姆，你为什么不播放那个片段呢？等一下，那一集里发生的另一件事是，那是一个，那是一个充满挑战的一集，因为我们需要拍的东西很多，而且自然因素也很棘手。我记得当时冷得要命，有取暖灯，有时天气又炎热难耐，所有这些都在一天之内发生，所以那一集有许多额外的挑战。有一天，眼看着日落前我们根本不可能
our day by sunset we had just way more to shoot than was actually possible to shoot in that day with our challenges and he said to me at one point Jen let's like divide up you work with the actors and I'll do the tech stuff and it was only for a brief amount of time but it was one of just a thrill of mine that I was able to do that and kind of start talking to the actors in a slightly different way and start thinking about the course of being a director and it all started with that episode him giving me a little bit of that responsibility because it was just too much to get done I'm so grateful for Harold and I it's one of the biggest thrills of my career that I got to work with him and guys
拍完当天的任务，我们要拍的东西实在太多了，在面临种种挑战的那一天里根本不可能全部拍完，他有一次对我说，珍，我们分工吧，你跟演员们合作，我来搞定技术方面的事情。虽然只有短短的一小段时间，但能够做到这一点，并且开始以一种略微不同的方式与演员交谈，开始思考成为一名导演的历程，这对我来说简直是巨大的震撼。这一切都始于那一集，他交给我一点那样的责任，因为要完成的工作实在太多了。我非常感激哈罗德，能够与他合作是我职业生涯中最震撼的经历之一，伙计们，
Jen ended up directing two episodes of the office she directed crime aid and the promotion it just fit so perfectly that he extended that to her and shared that with her and how lucky were we yeah well guys that's beach games that is beach games thank you so much for listening this was so wonderful to rewatch I loved it I loved it this was one of my favorite weeks to prepare me to sure yeah and to shoot we got to live it and relive it what a gift well next week we have a really big week it's the job and we're wrapping up season three now we're going to divide the job into two parts because it's an hour long episode we're going to have the job part one and the job part two but it's all going to be good all
珍最后执导了《办公室》的两集，她执导了《犯罪援助》和《晋升》。他把机会延伸给她并与她分享这一切，实在是太契合了。我们是多么幸运啊。好吧，伙计们，这就是《海滩游戏》，这就是《海滩游戏》。非常感谢你们的收听，重看这一集感觉太棒了，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。这是我准备起来最喜欢的几周之一，真的，而且去拍摄也是。我们曾经身历其中，如今又重温了一遍，真是一份厚礼。好吧，下周我们将迎来非常重大的一周，那是《工作》这一集，我们要为第三季画上句号了。现在我们要把《工作》分成两部分，因为它是一个小时长的剧集，我们将推出《工作》（上）和《工作》（下），但总之都会很精彩的。
right guys we'll see you next week have a good one we love you thank you for listening to office ladies office ladies is produced by ear will Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey our producer is Cody Fisher our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer and our associate producer is Ainsley bubukko our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton for ad-free versions of office ladies go to stitcher premium dot com for a free one month trial of stitcher premium use code office There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了，伙计们，我们下周见。祝你们过得愉快，我们爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》播客。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西主演，我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是艾因利·布布科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitcherpremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码office。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。